I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Angela. Hey, lady. It's very good to see your face today. Same. I feel the same way. Oh, I said lady right out of the gate. Jenna, some people love the lady and some people don't love the lady. I want to get a t-shirt that just says lady. Lady. All right. What are we talking about today? Today we are talking about season three, episode 18,
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来了一档终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。你好，安吉拉。嘿，女士。今天很高兴看到你的脸。我也是。我有同感。哦，我一开始就叫了女士。珍娜，有些人喜欢女士，有些人不喜欢女士。我想买一件印着“女士”字样的T恤。女士。好吧。我们今天在聊什么？今天我们聊的是第三季第18集，
the negotiation. It was written by Mike Sher and directed by Jeff Blitz. Those are two powerhouses of comedy. Yes, this is a good team. Here is a summary. Angered by Pam's confession that she and Jim shared a kiss, Roy tries to attack Jim in The Office. I mean, right out of the gate. That's the first scene, everybody. Yeah. Jim is spared by Dwight's quick thinking, aka pepper spray. Roy is fired and Darryl tries to leverage it into a raise. But upon hearing how little Michael makes at his job, Darryl, Toby and Michael drive to corporate so Michael can ask for his own raise. Roy takes Pam out for coffee to apologize and they break it off for good. This is it. No more Pam and Roy guys. And then at the end of the show,
即《谈判》。本剧由迈克·舒尔编剧，杰夫·布里茨执导。这两位都是喜剧界的中流砥柱。没错，这是一个很棒的团队。以下是剧情梗概。由于潘坦白了她和吉姆接吻过，罗伊大怒，试图在办公室里袭击吉姆。我的意思是，一开场就是这样。这是第一个镜头，各位。是的。吉姆因为德怀特的急智——也就是辣椒喷雾——而幸免于难。罗伊被解雇了，而达里尔试图借此争取加薪。但一听说迈克尔的工资有多低，达里尔、托比和迈克尔便开车去了总公司，好让迈克尔也要求加薪。罗伊带潘去喝咖啡以示道歉，两人彻底分手了。就是这样。各位，潘和罗伊再无可能了。然后在这个片段的最后，
Jim catches Dwight and Angela kissing in The Office. It's a lot. It's a lot. Fast fact number one, this episode was a super sized episode of The Office. And as a result, Angela, I think, am I right? There are no deleted scenes for this episode. There are none on the DVDs. Now, I don't know if there's some secret NBC archive somewhere, but there aren't any that we know of. I think we used it all. It's all in there, guys. Now, here's a little bit of a fact. This is a fact within a fact. I was going to say a little bit of a fact. What's happening? This episode, like I said, was written by Mike Shor, who was nominated for an Emmy Award for writing this episode. Oh, he should have won. Did he win? He did
吉姆撞见德怀特和安吉拉在办公室里接吻。信息量真的很大。信息量太大了。趣味冷知识一，这一集是《办公室》的超长集。因此，安吉拉，我想，我没记错吧？这一集没有删减片段。DVD里完全没有。现在，我不知道NBC某个地方是不是有什么秘密档案，但据我们所知是没有的。我想我们全用上了。全在里面了，各位。现在，还有一小条冷知识。这是一个藏在冷知识里的冷知识。我本来想说是个小冷知识。怎么回事？正如我所说，这一集是由迈克·舒尔编剧的，他曾因这一集的剧本获得艾美奖提名。哦，他本该得奖的。他得奖了吗？他没
not. Oh, boo. He lost to Greg Daniels, who won for Gay Witch Hunt. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. You're all right with that. You're like, all right. The Office won. Keep it in the family. That's right. Yay. All right. Well, that was fun. All right. Well, now I'm going to give you fast fact number two. In this episode, you remember Michael says that he got tips on how to negotiate from Wikipedia. Yes. And some of the stuff that he says that he found on Wikipedia is stuff like, you have to suddenly change the location or refuse to talk first. Yes. Well, we had a fan question from Brianna Kernan, Zhu Yuang, Charlie Altman, Shay Quiz, and Jeremy Sharp. They all asked, were the interview tips that Michael was using actually
有。哦，嘘。他输给了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，后者凭借《同性恋女巫大搜捕》获奖了。哦，好吧。好吧。好吧。你觉得这倒也行。你就像是，好吧。《办公室》赢了。肥水不流外人田。没错。耶。好吧，那挺有趣的。好了，现在我要告诉你趣味冷知识二。在本集里，你还记得迈克尔说他从维基百科上获得了如何谈判的秘诀吗？是的。而他所说的那些在维基百科上找到的东西，比如你必须突然改变地点或者拒绝先开口。是的。好吧，我们收到了来自布丽安娜·科南、朱洋、查理·奥尔特曼、谢伊·奎兹和杰里米·夏普的粉丝提问。他们都问，迈克尔使用的那些面试技巧真的是
from Wikipedia, or did the writers make them up? Okay. None of that stuff was on Wikipedia for real. The writers just made that up. Yeah. I, you know, Jen, I did a mini deep dive on the art of negotiation for this episode. And I can confirm because I went to the actual Wikipedia page for negotiating. And those are not on there. Well, you know, after this episode aired, there was a major stir. Really? Fans started going on to the negotiation page of Wikipedia, and they started changing it to reflect Michael's advice. That's awesome. I mean, not, I mean, don't, don't be hackers guys, but that's funny. And the administrators at Wikipedia had to put the page in, I guess, what is called semi protection mode. And that
来自维基百科，还是编剧们编出来的？好吧。那些东西实际上根本不在维基百科上。那是编剧们编出来的。是的，你知道的，珍娜，为了这一集，我专门对谈判的艺术进行了一番微深入研究。我可以证实，因为我访问了维基百科上关于谈判的实际页面，上面根本没有那些内容。好吧，你知道的，这一集播出后，引起了轩然大波。真的吗？粉丝们开始登录维基百科的谈判页面，他们开始修改内容以体现迈克尔的建议。太棒了。我是说，不是，我是说——大家别当黑客啊，但这也太逗了。维基百科的管理员们不得不把这个页面设为，我猜，所谓的半保护模式。而这
limits who's allowed to edit a page. So any user that had an account that was less than four days old, or anyone who's trying to put a post up as anonymous, were forbidden. And then they had other administrators who would go in and delete all of the fake negotiation advice. That was just Michael Scott. Oh my goodness, you guys. But it was a whole thing. They were like articles written about it in USA Today. Oh, wow. Yeah, it caused a stir. Stirring it up office fans. I'm going through these quickly, Angela, because we have some exciting news, which is part of fast fact number three. Yes. This episode marks the return of Ed Helms as Andy Bernard. But it also marks the last regular appearance of Roy played
限制了谁有资格编辑页面。所以任何拥有不到四天的新账号的用户，或者任何试图以匿名身份发帖的人，都被禁止了。然后他们还有其他管理员会去删除所有虚假的谈判建议。那全都是迈克尔·斯科特的内容。哦天哪，伙计们。但这闹得沸沸扬扬的。甚至有文章刊登在《今日美国》上。哦，哇。是的，引发了轰动。办公室粉丝们正在推波助澜。珍娜，我得快点过这些，因为我们有一些激动人心的消息，这正是趣味冷知识三的一部分。是的。这一集标志着埃德·赫尔姆斯饰演的安迪·伯纳德的回归。但这也标志着由大卫·德曼饰演的罗伊的最后一次常规出场。现在罗伊以后还会偶尔回来，但这确实正式宣告了潘和罗伊关系的结束。我们觉得我们必须通过采访罗伊本人大卫·德曼来纪念这一时刻。而且和他聊天我们觉得太有趣了。萨姆，你能播放那段采访吗？大卫·德曼。你好。欢迎来到办公室女士节目。你好，女士们。嘿，大卫，很高兴见到你。好久不见了。好久不见。确实如此。好吧，大卫，我们总是喜欢从询问嘉宾是如何加入这部剧的开始聊起。我的一个死党，他是个演员，我在纽约的一个朋友，他看了英版《办公室》，他打电话给我说，老兄，你一定要看这部剧。太棒了。你会爱上它的。
by David Denman. Now Roy will continue to come back now and then, but this really officially ends the Pam Roy relationship. And we felt like we had to mark this occasion by talking to Roy himself, David Denman. And we had so much fun talking to him. Sam, can you play that interview? David Denman. Hello. Welcome to office, ladies. Hello, ladies. Hey, David, it's so good to see you. Been a long time. It's been a long time. It has. Well, David, we always like to start by asking our guests how they came to be on the show. My buddy, who is an actor, a friend of mine in New York, he watched the British office and he called me and said, dude, you've got to watch the show. It's amazing. You're going to love
电视上从来没有过这样的作品。我听说他们正在拍美版。你一定要想办法加入进去。所以我看了，然后我觉得，天哪，这简直是天才之作。而且你知道的，剧里有几个和我年龄相仿的家伙，于是我给我的经纪人打电话说，嘿，我听说他们在拍美版的《办公室》。然后他说，对，对，对。我说，我很想加入进去。接着他说，真的吗？你想演那个？我说，对啊，你这话什么意思？因为他说，不知道，他们在找即兴喜剧演员。而我就想，行吧，你知道的，我可是从茱莉亚学院毕业的。我学过即兴表演，还有莎士比亚以及很多其他东西。这并不意味着，仅仅因为我没有去过，你知道的，
it. There's nothing like it on TV. And I hear they're doing an American version. You've got to try to get in on that. So I watched it and I was like, Oh my God, this is genius. And there was, you know, a couple of guys, my age on the show, and I called my agent and I was like, Hey, I hear they're doing an American version of the office. And he goes, Yeah, yeah. And I go, I'd love to get in on that. And he goes, You really? You want to do that? I go, Yeah, what do you mean? Because I don't know, they're looking for improv comedians. And I'm like, Yeah, you know, I went to Juilliard. I did study improv along with Shakespeare and many other things. It's not just because I didn't go to, you
即兴奥林匹克或类似的地方，并不意味着我对这方面不感兴趣，也不意味着我不具备这种能力。我的工具箱里有——哦，好吧。于是他打了个电话，除了罗伊之外，所有角色都已经选好了。所以我说，行，我很乐意去试镜那个角色。那个小小的举动改变了我的职业生涯。好吧，大卫，我记得你是最早最早被选中的演员之一。你参加了我们最初的那次剧本围读，当时安吉拉甚至都还没到场。他们甚至还没填满办公室的其他角色。当时只有史蒂夫、约翰、雷恩、比杰、我、菲利丝和你。这就是参加第一次剧本围读的所有人。我记得艾莉森·琼斯带了她的宝丽来相机。
know, improv Olympic or whatever. It doesn't mean I don't have an interest in that and don't have that. My toolboxing is, Oh, okay. So he called over and all the parts were cast except for Roy. And so I said, Yeah, I'd love to go in for that part. That little thing changed my career. Well, David, I remember that you were one of the very, very first people cast. You were at our first original table read that Angela was not even at. They hadn't even filled out the rest of the office. It was just Steve, John, Rain, BJ, me, Phyllis and you. That's who was at the first table read. And I remember Alison Jones brought her Polaroid camera.
并且她为我们每个人拍了一张宝丽来照片，因为她说这是她在剧本围读会上为演员拍摄他们第一部剧的照片的传统。你还留着你的那张吗？我的记忆稍微有点不同。我知道她带了宝丽来相机。而且她为自己拍了一张照片，她对她第一部剧的每一次剧本围读都这么做。然后你说，哦，我也想要一张。这是另一张，然后她给了你。我不认为除了那两张之外，还有任何人拥有那些照片。好吧，听起来确实像我干的事。谢谢你，大卫，因为珍娜之前一直在说这个。谢谢你把事情澄清了。
And she took a Polaroid picture for each of us because she said that's a tradition of hers at table reads for actors at their for their first series. Do you still have yours? I remember it slightly different. I know she brought the Polaroid camera. And she took a picture for herself that she did on every table read of her first show. And you said, Oh, I want one of those. This is another one and gave it to you. I don't think anyone else has any of those photos besides those two. Okay, that sounds like me. Thank you, David, because Jenna has talked about this. And thank you for setting that straight.
好吧，这就解释了为什么除了我之外没有人有了。对啊，珍娜，也许你以后该停止问那个问题了，特别是对最初参与剧本围读的人。哦，天哪。好吧，大卫，我只记得初次见到你时感到非常兴奋。而且我们有戏剧表演的渊源，因为我也拿到了戏剧学位。我立刻就喜欢上你了。我立刻就喜欢你了。不，我们确实很合得来。那部剧一开始最有趣的地方在于，你们所有人被困在办公室里好几个小时好几个小时。通常当你拍摄一部剧时，会是这样的，哦，我们先拍那场戏，然后去拍那场戏。但因为他们这种拍摄方式，你知道的，采用了
Well, that explains why no one else has one but me. Yeah, maybe you should stop asking that question, Jenna, to the original table read people. Oh, my gosh. Well, David, I just remember meeting you and being so excited. And we had that theater connection because I also got a theater degree. I just liked you immediately. I immediately liked you. No, we definitely hit it off. It was what was fun about that show in the beginning was you guys were all stuck in the office for hours and hours and hours. And usually when you film a series, it's like, Oh, we'll shoot that scene. And then we'll go shoot that scene. But because the way they filmed this with, you know, a
伪纪录片风格，把摄像机在整个办公室里甩来甩去，他们需要每个人整天都坐在背景里。所以每当我出现在片场时，你们这群人已经快要精神崩溃了。你们会说，哦，来了一个新人。嗨。每次我到那儿，你们都表现得极其热情。对此我非常感激。所以，是的，我们确实一拍即合。不过，我确实记得珍娜来到片场时说，猜猜我周末干嘛了？我就问，干嘛了？然后她说，我和大卫打扑克去了。我就想，这到底是怎么回事？你们在哪儿？你们竟然在一起混。你们在一个人的车库里打扑克。天哪，这到底是什么我从未涉足的全新生活？我知道你从来没学过扑克，安吉拉。你错过了很多乐趣。好吧，你肯定不会想让我在你们的扑克桌上的。我是说，我，我的意思是，有一次我和别人玩，我手里有一对3，我以为自己能赢下整场比赛。但我想那并不是，你知道的，我也不太清楚。我不擅长这个，伙计们。好吧，如果我们玩的是真金白银，我们可太想让你上我们的扑克桌了。不，你们才不想呢，因为我是那种会把所有筹码都押上的人，然后所有人都会说，等等，发生什么事了？
documentary style where they whipped the camera across the whole office, they needed everyone to sit in the background all day long. So you guys would always be losing your mind by the time I showed up on set. You were like, Oh, there's a new person. Hi. And you were very enthusiastic every time I got there. And I was very grateful for it. You know, so yeah, we definitely hit it off. I do remember Jenna coming to set, though, and being like, guess what I did this weekend? I was like, what? And she was like, I played poker with David. And I was like, what is happening? Where are you guys? You guys are like hanging out. You're playing poker in
我记得那是在雷恩的车库里，就像，我们就在一个小扑克桌旁。但我记得我赢了你的一大把彩池，珍娜，就一次，你当时简直要抓狂了。你简直不敢相信你、你竟然在那一手牌里输给了我。我觉得我之后再也没有赢过你的一手牌，但那一次真的让我印象深刻，你当时就是太不敢相信我赢了你。你还记得吗？那是我的美好回忆。我觉得我每次输了而且没料到的时候，就会表现得很戏剧化。所以，大卫，珍娜和我之前聊过，我们如何为各自的角色构建背景故事，
someone's garage. Like, what's this whole other life I need to get in on? I know you never learned poker, Angela. You missed out on a lot. Well, you wouldn't want me at your poker table. I mean, I, I mean, one time I played with, and I had like a pair of threes and I thought I could win the whole thing. But I guess that's not, you know, I don't know. I'm not good at it guys. Well, if we're playing for real money, we would want you at our poker table. No, you wouldn't because I'm the person that's like all in and everyone's like, wait, what's happening?
比如我会给安吉拉·马丁找出各种她会做出某种反应的理由，而珍娜也分享了她的潘的背景故事。你对罗伊和潘是怎么看的？你为他们的关系和罗伊本人虚构过背景故事吗？是的，我确实有背景故事。但我只是，你知道的，我假设这两个人在高中时相识，他们开始约会，然后，你知道的，他们就自然而然地陷入了这种，这种动态中，他们俩谁——好吧，绝对地，我甚至不认为罗伊曾经想要，你知道的，结婚。最初，我以为这只是，哦，这是我们接下来该做的事。这也是我们接下来该做的事。直到多年以后
I remember that like in rain's garage, like, and here we are in a little poker table. But I remember I took down a big pot opposite you, Jenna, once and you lost your mind. You could not believe that I, that I had beat you in that hand. I don't think I ever won another hand against you, but that one just set the time you were just so limited that I'd beat you. And do you remember that? That's my fond memory. I feel like I would often get dramatic when I lost and wasn't expecting it. So, David, Jenna and I have talked a little bit how we give our characters backstories
当他，你知道的，当他快要失去潘的时候，他才觉得，哦，我其实很在乎这个人，我必须在这段感情上付出一些努力。而且，你知道的，对于任何关系，你都必须为此付出一些精力。我不认为，我不认为罗伊曾经考虑过这一点，直到为时已晚。我上学时认识了一群、跟一些像，有几个头脑简单四肢发达的家伙，我是照着他们来塑造这个角色的。我是说，我不会说是谁，但我就是这样看待罗伊的。所以当时我想，哦，这会是嘲笑那些家伙的好方法。然后接下来我知道的就是我要在余生中饰演这些角色了。那可不全都是
like I would give Angela Martin reasons why she would react one way and Jenna has shared her Pam backstory. And what was your take on Roy and Pam? Did you invent a backstory for their relationship and for Roy? Yeah, I did definitely have backstory. But I just, you know, I assume that these guys met in high school, they started dating and, you know, they just kind of fell into this, you know, this dynamic where neither one of them, well, definitely, I don't even think Roy wanted to, you know, get married. Initially, I think it was just like, Oh, this is what we're supposed to do next. And this was supposed to do next. And it wasn't until years later
完全真实的。好吧，这太有趣了，因为你，我的意思是，了解你之后，你其实更像是一个知识分子型的创意人才。谢谢你。我很感激。不过你是个户外运动爱好者，罗伊的那一部分倒是挺适合你的。我觉得，我的意思是，罗伊会玩水上摩托，但你知道的，你也喜欢户外活动之类。我是。我确实喜欢户外活动。我是说，我会去，我会去背包远足之类的。我不知道罗伊是不是一定是那样，他更像是那种，我要搞辆房车和水上摩托
that like, you know, when he was going to lose Pam that like he was like, Oh, I actually care about this person and I have to put some work into this. And, you know, with any relationship, you have to put some effort into it. And I don't think I don't think Roy was had ever thought about that until it was too late. And I went to school with a bunch with some like, a couple of meatheads that I sort of fashioned this guy after. I mean, I'm not going to say who they were, but that's kind of where I saw Roy. And so I thought at the time I was like, Oh, this will be a great way to make fun of those guys. And then the next thing I know I'm playing these parts for the rest of my life. That's not all that's
然后到处闲逛喝几杯啤酒的那种人。是的，而且，这就是他的，这就是他的户外运动方式。对吧。他会把一辆四轮全地形车装满啤酒，大概还会在树林里做出一些糟糕的选择。对。是的。好吧，大卫，我完全能理解你为什么会陷入某种类型化角色的套路中，因为我昨天刚刚做了一个采访，采访我的人说，所以，安吉拉，你经常扮演恶人。你在什么剧里都有点像个恶人。然后我说，嗯，是的，我差不多已经习惯了去演那个刻薄女或怪咖。这已经有点成为我的标志了。
entirely true. Well, it's so funny because you, I mean, like knowing you, you're such like more of like an intellectual creative. Thank you. I appreciate that. You're an outdoorsman though, like that part of Roy fits you. I think like, I mean, Roy is jet skiing, but you know, you like the outdoors and stuff. I do. I do like the outdoors. I mean, I go, I go out backpacking stuff like that. I don't know if Roy is necessarily that he's more of like a, let's get my RV and my jet ski
一旦你落入那个框框，人们很难看到那个框框之外的你。而且，这部剧的成功一直在持续，持续，持续，持续，这太棒了。它现在比以往任何时候都更受欢迎。而且，你知道的，如果你足够幸运能够成为人们喜爱并沉浸其中的事物的一部分，那真的很令人兴奋。但是，能够成为融入文化的一部分的东西，那是如此罕见，又是如此不可能去实现的一部分，以至于我每天都由衷地感激自己能够成为这部剧的一小部分，因为那真的，真的，真的非常罕见。对。
and like hang out and drink some beers. Yeah. And, uh, and that's his, that's his outdoorsman. Right. He's going to load up a four wheeler with a bunch of beer, probably make some bad choices in the woods. Yeah. Yeah. Well, David, I totally relate to how you can kind of fall into a casting rut because I just did an interview yesterday and the person interviewing me said, so Angela, you often play the heel. You're kind of a heel in everything. And I was like, um, yes, I have sort of made a way of playing the bitch or the weirdo. It's kind of become my thing.
所以，大卫，在第三季开始的时候，你回来上班时，身材简直好到爆。我们所有人都注意到了，这是因为你夏天拍了一部电影角色，他们把它写进了剧情里，还是格雷格把你拉到一边，告诉你这个想法，说罗伊应该回来，表现得对重新赢得潘芳心充满热忱？而你为了这部剧进行了这样的改造。这完全是为了这部剧，但它是一个，而且这是和格雷格的一场对话。我不会说是格雷格说，嘿，去把身材练好。但他确实说过，嗯，他确实把我拉到一边说，嘿，嗯，我希望，我下季想让你成为吉姆更强劲的争夺对手。
It's hard for people to see you outside of that box once you're in it. And, and then like the success of the show has just continued on and on and on and on, which is fantastic. It's more popular now than it ever was. And, uh, you know, if you're lucky enough to be part of something that like people enjoy and get into and that's exciting. But when you, to be part of something that gets into the culture of that is so rare and so impossible to, to be a part of that, I'm constantly grateful every day that I got to be in a little part part of this show. Cause that's, you know, very, very, very rare. Yeah.
我说，真的吗？他说，对。我说，我们该怎么做？我的意思是，我们已经把这家伙塑造得像个大笨蛋了。我不知道怎么会有人去支持罗伊。然后他说，嗯，我觉得，我觉得，我觉得你可以做点什么让它行得通，等我们同时也能，你知道的，写出相应的剧本时，我们就给他们提供那个机会。我说，好吧，我说，那我是不是该把身材练好了。然后我们的一个摄像师后来成了导演，你知道的，我们的老朋友马特·索恩，他说，你应该参加这个铁人三项。我说，你疯了吗？我才不参加什么铁人三项。我甚至不怎么，我勉强跑步。我的意思是，他当时说，你行的
So David, at the beginning of season three, you came back to work and you were like super fit. We all noticed, was this because you had done a movie roll over the summer and they wrote it into the plot or did Greg get you aside and tell you this idea that Roy should come back and be all like excited to win Pam back. And you sort of transformed for the show. It was all for the show, but it was, and it was a conversation with Greg. I wouldn't say Greg said, Hey, go get in shape. But he did say, um, he did take me aside and said, Hey, uh, I want, I got the, I'd like to make you more of a rival of Jim's next season.
我跟你说，你一定行。而我说，不，不，老兄，那绝对不可能发生。我的意思是，我，我，我在高中的第一年玩过水球。所以我算是个挺不错的游泳运动员，我不担心这个，但我从来没骑过自行车。然后他就像是，我知道怎么搞，老兄，我可以给你弄辆自行车，然后我们觉得，你应该直接去参加。而且，你知道的，就是那次对话加上格雷格想要让罗伊更具竞争对手意识的想法，直接把这一切都付诸行动了。于是我开始为马里布铁人三项赛进行训练，结果我坚持了大约10年，我大概每年都去参加，连续练了大约10年。办公室里的好多其他人也加入了进来。我不知道
And I said, really? And he goes, yeah. I said, how are we going to do that? I mean, we've really made this guy such a knucklehead. I don't know how anyone's going to root for Roy. And he goes, well, I think, I think, I think you can do something and make it work when we can also, you know, write it. So, so we give them that opportunity. And I said, okay, I said, well, I probably should get in a shape then. He goes, okay, if you want to. And one of our camera operators who became a director, you know, our buddy Matt Sohn, he was like, you should do the, this triathlon. And I was like, are you out of your mind? I'm not doing a triathlon. I don't even, I barely run. I mean, he was like, you can
你们俩中有人参加过吗？我从来没参加过，但我记得这个，大卫。我记得剧组里的很多小伙子，还有一些女士们。泰瑞·温伯格，对吧？泰瑞·温伯格身材保持得太好了。她真的是全力以赴。我每年都能看到她在那里。她现在还在坚持。你们每次回来都会带着照片，简直难以置信。是的。而且那总是和艾美奖在同一个周末，这就变成了，早上先去参加铁人三项赛，然后回去换衣服，晚上再去参加任何派对，这对我来说简直太搞笑了。我想说的是，大卫，我其实很想那么做，但安吉拉觉得我没有运动天赋。这可完全不是事实。谢谢。请大声而清晰地
do it. I'm telling you, you can do it. And I'm like, no, no, man, that's never going to happen. I mean, I, I, I played water polo in high school for like my freshman year. So I was a pretty good swimmer. I wasn't worried about that, but I hadn't ever been on a bike. And he was like, I know guys, I can get you a bike and like we should, you should just do it. And, you know, it was like that conversation with Greg's idea of trying to make, you know, Roy more of a rival, just kind of put it all into motion. And so I started training for the Malibu Triathlon, which I ended up doing like 10, I did that for like 10 years, I think, every year. And so many other people from the office got joined in on that. I don't know
说给办公室女士们的听众听，拜托。是的，我需要听到你对这个论点的支持。好的。首先，你，安吉拉，你一定得记住这一点，我讨厌把你架在火上烤，但还记得那一年珍娜决定开始健身，然后说，我这就去。我一定行。而我当时的反应是，为你感到高兴。然后她还登上了《Shape》杂志的封面，穿着比基尼，状态简直好极了。她看起来太棒了。大卫，我要对你说的重点是这个。我的论点并不是指珍娜在想要保持身材时就做不到。这女人可是个狠角色。你知道的，她还制作过一张名为《斯克兰顿之声》的混音带。她写了一份三页的
if you, if either of you guys ever did it, but I never did it, but I remember this, David. I remember a bunch of the guys on the crew and some of the women as well. Terri Weinberg, right? Terri Weinberg is like so fit. She really went all out. I see her out there every year. She still does it. You guys would come back with photos and it was incredible. Yeah. And it was always the same weekend as the Emmys, which was like, go do the, go do the triathlon in the morning and then go change and go to any party that night, which was hilarious to me. I'm like, well, I would have loved to have done that, David, but Angela doesn't think I have the athleticism. Now that's not true at all. Thank you. Say it
关于潘的背景故事的文件。当她想要健身时，天哪，她绝对能把身材练好。但她能做一个侧手翻、一个后空翻，然后把一颗手榴弹扔向空中，接着抓上一根绳子在停车场荡来荡去吗？我见她提着一把吉他穿过机场。大卫，我看到她试图把一把吉他带上飞机。好吧。听着，关于把吉他带上飞机或者在停车场做后空翻、荡绳子这事，我收回刚才的话，而且我也不知道，难道她要成为下一个劳拉·克劳夫特吗？大概不会。但这才是我的观点，大卫。她绝对能参加铁人三项。这就是我想说的。我，听着，我没说她不能参加铁人三项。珍娜插话
loud and clear for the office ladies audience, please. Yeah, I need to hear your support for this argument. Okay. First of all, do you, you, Angela, you have to remember this and I hate to put you on one point, but remember the year that Jenna decided to get into shape and was like, and she was like, I'm doing it. I am doing it. And I'm like, good for you. And she was on the cover of like shape magazine and a bikini and she looked phenomenal. She looked phenomenal. David, here is what I'm saying to you. My argument is not that Jenna cannot get into shape when she wants to get into shape. The woman is hardcore. You know, she also made a mix tape called sounds of Scranton. She wrote a three page
是为了损我，并试图把你拉到她那边。我觉得她绝对能参加铁人三项。随便啦。我觉得她会成为团队领袖。她会给每个人排好时间表。毫无疑问她能参加铁人三项。随便啦。哦，天哪。开始吐槽了。我们这儿开始互相吐槽了。好吧，关于这个采访我还有一个问题。我要继续推进了。大卫，总的来说，你在剧中有没有什么最喜欢的场景？有什么仅仅因为某种原因就让你深爱的片段吗？我确实有一个特别记得的时刻，但那并不是任何在镜头前的画面。那是，我们在拍《酒水游轮》那一集。那是个漫长的夜晚。第二天早上，就在我们杀青的时候，他们
document about the background of Pam. When she wants to get into shape by God, she gets in shape. But could she do a cartwheel and a backflip and throw a grenade in the air and then jump on a rope and swing across a parking lot? I've seen her carry a guitar through an airport. David, I saw her try to get a guitar on a plane. Okay. Look, I stand corrected in regards to, to getting a guitar on a plane or doing a backflip to a parking lot, swing on a rope and I don't know, like, is she going to be the next Laura Croft? Probably not. But this is my point. David, she could do a triathlon. That's all I'm saying. I, listen, I didn't say she couldn't do a triathlon. Jenna jumped
有一艘浮筒船，我和史蒂夫跳上了那艘浮筒船，当太阳升起时，我们在长滩港全速驰骋。那种感觉，简直太棒了。不知为什么，比起其他任何事情，我对那部剧中这段时光的记忆最深刻的就是那一刻。我太喜欢这个了。好吧，大卫，我只是想听听你对安吉拉和罗伊这整件事的看法，因为网上有很多人。有一个Reddit的讨论串说安吉拉和罗伊曾有过一段秘密恋情。我们和格雷格聊过这个。格雷格当时的反应是，我，也许他如果在这部剧里呆得更久一点的话，但，nah，我不这么认为。不过，不过我们能理解为什么罗伊会对安吉拉有吸引力，毕竟是个高大威猛的帅哥嘛。
in to give me shade and try to get you on her side. I think she could do a triathlon. Whatever. I think she would be the team leader. She'd have everyone on a schedule. No doubt she could do a triathlon. Whatever. Oh, Lord. Sass. We got some sass happening. All right. Well, I have a question for this interview. I'm moving us along. David, in general, do you have any favorite scenes from your time on the show? Anything you just loved for any reason? I do have a moment that I remember specifically, but it wasn't anything that was on camera. It was, we were shooting the booze cruise episode. It was a long night. And the next morning, like we, as we were wrapping, they
我记得那是，你会选谁？我觉得，我觉得罗伊当时的反应是，哇，她真辣。我不知道，我，就像，正如格雷格所说，我觉得如果他留在这部剧中，如果我在这部剧里呆得更久一点的话，那会是一个有趣的转折，可以加入其中来制造冲突。在潘面前和安吉拉展开报复性约会，那该有多好玩啊？哦，哦，对。哦，不，百分之百。那会是，她绝对会对此感兴趣的。而且罗伊也会感兴趣的，我敢肯定。哦，那太搞笑了。对。
had a pontoon boat and Steve and I jumped in the pontoon boat and we blazed through Long Beach Harbor as the sun was coming up. And it was like, it was awesome. And I just, for some reason, remember that moment of my time on that show more than anything else. I love that. Well, David, I just want to get your take on the whole Angela and Roy thing because there's a lot of people online. There's like a Reddit thread that Angela and Roy were having some secret love affair. We talked to Greg about it. Greg was like, I'm, I'm maybe he had stayed on the show longer, but nah, I don't think so. But, but we could see where Roy would appeal to Angela, sort of this big gallant fella.
好吧，大卫，你有很多和克雷格·罗宾逊的对手戏。你刚才提到我们在办公室里待了很长时间，但你拍了所有那些仓库的戏，而且很多时候你们俩都被分到了一组。你有什么关于和克雷格合作的故事吗，或者那是什么体验？我太爱那个老兄了。就像你一样，我和他相处得非常好，而且在刚开始的时候，我们在工作之外经常一起闲逛。我一直试图让他去参加铁人三项，但他对此毫无兴趣，不过我们差点就去参加了，几乎参加了泥泞搭档障碍赛，这是一场非常疯狂的比赛，你要在一个障碍赛道上
I remember that, like, who would you do? I think, I think Roy was like, yeah, she's hot. I don't, I don't, I like, like Greg said, I think if he'd been on the show, if I'd been on the show longer, that would have been a fun, you know, twist to throw in there to just create conflict. How much fun would it have been to revenge date Angela in front of Pam? Oh, oh yeah. Oh no, 100%. That would have been, that would have been, she would have totally been into that. And Roy would have been into that too, I'm sure. Oh, that would have been funny. Yeah.
闯关，而且，字面意思，你和搭档或好几个人一起，互相帮助爬过这些障碍赛道，穿过泥潭，甚至还会被电击，这简直是最疯狂的——被电击？对。什么？为什么？对。这听起来像是什么糟糕的兄弟会恶性整蛊。
Well, David, you got to have a lot of scenes with Craig Robinson. You sort of mentioned that we spent a lot of time in the office, but you got to do all those warehouse scenes and oftentimes the two of you were paired up. Do you have any stories from working with Craig or what that was like? I love that dude. Like, like you, I got along with him really well and we hung out outside of work quite a bit at the beginning. And I was trying to get him to do the triathlon, which he was not into, but we almost did, almost a muddy buddy, which is this like crazy race where you like go on this obstacle course like, and you get, I mean, literally you like
这太可怕了，我只去过一次，绝对不会再去第二次了。但任何参加过的人都知道，里面有一个障碍，你必须趴在地上，穿过泥潭，然后他们挂着一些，类似于带电流的电线，一旦碰到你的身体就会电你。这就像是为了让你保持低姿势，但当你像我这么大块头的时候，你就会一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地被电击。这简直是有史以来最糟糕的事情。克雷格和我，我们一直在讨论这个，而且我们真的差一点就要去参加了。也许他当时只是对我很友好，才说“也许我会考虑一下吧”。
you do it with a partner or multiple people and you help each other like climb across these obstacle courses, you go through mud, you get electrocuted, like it's the most insane like electrocuted. Yeah. What? Why? Yeah. This sounds like electrocuting you. Yeah, this sounds like a bad frat hazing.
百分之百是的。我觉得他完全是在敷衍你。是的，老兄。这听起来真是个好主意。再见。哈哈，我太喜欢这个了。好吧，我的幻想就是克雷格和我能一起完成其中一次那样的冒险。现在我太老了。我才不想去呢。这太疯狂了。我20年前就不想去。好了，在这一集里，大卫，我们有一场在饥饿狐狸餐厅的戏，这可以说是潘和罗伊很长一段时间内的最后一场重头戏了
It is horrible and I did it once and I'll never, ever do it again. But anyone who's ever participated, they know there's this one obstacle course where you have to crawl on the ground on your, through the mud and they have these hanging like, like electric like currents that like once they touch your body, they zap you. And like it's to keep you down low, but when you're as big as I am, you just get zapped over and over and over again. It was the worst thing ever. Craig and I, like we talked about it all the time and we were going to, we were, we were so possibly going to do that. Um, maybe he just was just being nice to me saying maybe I'll think about it.
因为你确实还会回来，而且我们后来还有另一次推心置腹的谈话，但这场戏暂时画上了句号。我记得和你拍这场戏时感觉挺情绪化的，因为我知道你在《办公室》里的常规戏份要结束了。你对那有什么记忆吗？格雷格跟你谈过这件事吗？我跟你说，当我，当我得知这个消息时，我们正在进行剧本围读，就在那时克雷格接到了电话，或者就在那之前你们所有人都刚刚续签了两季，也许是三季合同吧。我不知道当时具体续了多少季，但每个人都在说，哦，天哪，太棒了。我当时就坐在格雷格旁边，我转向
100% he was. I think he was totally placating you. Yeah, man. That sounds like a great idea. Buh-bye. Yeah. Oh, I love that. Well, that's my fantasy that Craig and I would have done that one of those adventures together. Now I'm too old. I don't want to do it. It's nuts. I don't want to do it 20 years ago. Now on this episode, David, we have this scene at the Hungry Fox diner and it's kind of Pam and Roy's last big scene together for a while
格雷格对他说，我不会再回来了。然后他说，不，他说，但这并不是针对你。我只是得把罗密欧与朱丽叶凑到一起，而我觉得有你在这里我没法做到这一点。但是，我不想写死你，因为我想让你回来。我说，我懂。而且最酷的事情是，我说，那我去找个，你知道的，试播集演演可以吗？因为那正值试播集选角季的开始。他说，行，我觉得那可以。而且，通常情况下，因为他们不想让别人知道有什么变故发生，他们不会允许你那样做。就像你还在合同期内，所以他们不会允许你出演其他剧。
because you do come back and we have another kind of heart to heart it later, but this ends it for a while. And I remember shooting this scene with you and feeling kind of emotional because I knew that your regular time on the office was ending. Do you have any memories from that? Did Greg talk to you about that? I'll tell you, like when I, when I found out, we did a table read and right then Craig got the phone call or right before that you guys had all got picked up for two more seasons or maybe it was three seasons. I don't know how many seasons it was at that point, but everyone was like, oh my God, yay. And I was sitting right next to Greg and I turned to
所以他能让我去拍那个真的非常大度，我最后确实拿到了一个非常棒的试播集角色，虽然最后没被正式砍成剧，但对我来说是个很大的收获，而且绝对改变了我的职业生涯轨迹。在那之后不久，我们确实拍了这一集，我知道我要离开这部剧了，对我来说这确实也充满了情绪，因为我们已经成了很好的朋友，你知道吗？而且，我们，你知道的，我只是知道，这，这就要结束了。虽然我们后来确实还是朋友，但我们见面的频率没那么高了。你要工作，我也在忙别的事情。而且，你最后往往只会和与你一起工作的人成为朋友，这，这也就是
Greg and I go, I'm not coming back in my, and he goes, no, he goes, but it's not you. I just got to get Romeo and Juliet together and I just don't feel like I can do that with you here. And, but I don't want to kill you off because I want you to come back and I said, I get it. And the coolest thing ever was that I said, would it be okay for me to do like a, you know, a pilot or something? Because it was right at the beginning of pilot season. He goes, yeah, I think that would be okay. And, you know, oftentimes because they don't want people to know something's not going to happen, they won't let you do that. Like you're under contract and so they're not going to allow you to do another show.
人生在这些剧组里的常态。但是的，这绝对是情绪激动的，因为我确实觉得，我，这个剧组，你们已经成了一个大家庭。所以，是的，拍最后那场戏对我来说确实百感交集。大卫，你杀青时从片场拿走什么东西了吗？你有什么纪念品吗？你知道的，这很有趣。我没有，但我有一件——我不知道你们俩还记不记得这个——仓库所有人穿的那件夹克，其实是我去试镜时穿的那件。不会吧。对啊。对。当时有一件，我从老海军买的这件夹克，我穿着它去参加了试镜
And so he was very gracious to let me do that. And I ended up getting this really great pilot that ended up not going, but it was a, it was a big get for me and, and definitely changed the trajectory of my career. Shortly after that, we did shoot this episode and I knew that I was leaving the show and it was definitely, it was emotional for me too because we become really good friends, you know? And I, and we, you know, you know, I just knew that like it was, it was coming to an end. Like we did stay friends afterwards, but we didn't see each other as often. You're working and I'm off doing other things. And, you know, you just ended up becoming friends with the people you're working with. And, and, and that's just
格雷格说，我想要那件夹克。那夹克是哪儿来的？它看起来有点像那种假两件夹克，但其实不是。那是老海军生产的一种，你知道的，就像仓库员工穿的那种夹克。所以可怜的服装部门不得不打电话给老海军。他们打电话给我问，你从哪儿买的那件夹克？我必须弄到一件。因为格雷格说每个人都必须穿那个。于是他们买下了老海军仓库里所有能买到的那种夹克。所以我有那件原版夹克。我再也不穿它了。我把它放在某处了。你能想象如果你穿上那件夹克，然后珍娜，你们两个去吃午餐，只有你穿着那件夹克，就像珍娜头发半扎不扎那样，人们会觉得，
the way life goes on these, on these shows. But yeah, it was definitely emotional because I definitely felt like, you know, I, this cast, you know, you become a family. So yeah, it was definitely emotional for me to shoot that last scene. David, did you take anything from set when you wrapped? Do you have a memento? What would you know, it's funny. I don't, but I have, I don't know if you guys remember this, but like the jacket that all of the warehouse wears was my jacket that I auditioned with. No. Yeah. Yeah. There was a, I bought this jacket from Old Navy and I wore it to my audition
好吧，大卫，太谢谢你了。谢谢你们。很高兴能见到你们并叙叙旧。好吧，大卫，我们接下来能在这里聊聊你最近在忙些什么吗？嗯，这个我挺久以前就拍完了。因为疫情原因被推迟了，但我拍了一部由杰瑞德·巴特勒和莫瑞娜·巴卡琳主演的电影《格陵兰》，等这期节目播出时应该已经在院线上映了。这是一部灾难片。真的非常不错。我在里面演了一个非常、非常有趣的角色。关于这个我先不说太多。我还在拍一部叫《东城梦魇》的剧，和凯特·温丝莱特合作，我们当时正拍到一半，真的太棒了。天呐，大卫。太厉害了。她太棒了。这剧很棒。好吧，我真的为你
and Greg said, I want that jacket. Where does that jacket? And it's kind of looks like a dicky jacket, but it wasn't. It was this like, you know, like warehouse jacket that Old Navy made. And so poor costumes had to call Old Navy. They called me and they're like, where did you get that jacket? I have to get it. Cause Greg says everyone has to wear that. So then they bought every, every, you know, every thing they could get in stock of Old Navy's jacket. So I have that original jacket. I don't wear it anymore. I have it somewhere. Can you imagine if you put that jacket on and Jenna, the two of you met for lunch, just you in that jacket, like Jenna with her hair half up, half down, people would be like,
感到兴奋。凯特·温丝莱特是我的偶像之一。所以等你回来后，我们能一起出去喝一杯吗？我非常乐意效劳。我很乐意去喝一杯，那一定很有趣。大卫，谢谢你。非常感谢你。很高兴见到你。我迫不及待想看你最近所有的作品了。听起来都太棒了。谢谢你们，伙计们。很高兴见到你们。谢谢你，大卫。安吉拉，能和大卫聊天真是太棒了。我知道。我们能和剧组的每个人叙旧，真的度过了最美好的时光。不过，女士，你准备好对付这一集了吗，因为里面发生的事可真不少。哦，而且节奏飞快。伙计们，这一集一开场就是罗伊在
well, David, thank you so much. Thank you guys. It was really, really good to see you and reminisce. Well, David, what are you up to now that we can talk about here? Well, I finished this a while ago. It got pushed because of COVID, but I did this movie Greenland that's out with Jared Butler and Marina Bakkaran that I think will be in theaters by the time this airs. It's like a disaster movie. It's really good. I play a really, really fun character. I don't want to say anything about it. And I'm doing this series called Mayor of East Town with Kate Winslet that we were in the middle of filming and it's amazing. Holy moly, David. That's amazing. She's awesome. It's great. Well, I'm so excited
外面的停车场来回踱步。我觉得他好像在等，你知道的，等吉姆从大楼里出来，但吉姆根本没出来。对，那是下班时间，吉姆和凯伦正在，他们俩在打情骂俏，计划着接下来要做什么。而罗伊在停车场等得不耐烦了，他就直接闯进来了。对，他直接冲了进来，大喊着找吉姆，而潘的反应则是，哦，不。好吧，你注意到吉姆立刻就把目光转向你了吗？一副“要糟”的表情。对。然后发生了很多事。所以罗伊朝吉姆扑了过去。吉姆一把把凯伦推开。他就像是，我得把凯伦带离这个危险地带。就在罗伊的手抓到吉姆之前，德怀特
for you. Kate Winslet is one of my idols. So can we please go out for drinks when you get back? I will be happy to do that. I'd love to get drinks to be fun. David, thank you. Thank you so much. It's so wonderful to see you. And I can't wait to see all the things that you're up to. They sound so wonderful. Thank you, guys. So good to see you. Thanks, David. Angela, that was so great getting to talk to David. I know. We are just having the best time getting to see everyone from the show. But lady, are you ready to tackle this episode because a lot happens. Oh, and it happens fast. Guys, this episode opens with Roy pacing
突然窜出来，直接把辣椒喷雾喷到了罗伊脸。我的意思是，德怀特不只是喷了一下，他是把整个容器都浇在了罗伊脸上。而且这明显开始影响到休息室里的每一个人了。好吧，我记得杰夫·布里茨跟我们聊过这个。我们有过一番深入交谈，他说，听吧，遭受辣椒喷雾波及后果的绝不仅仅是那个直接中招的人。像这种喷射，是一个会在一定半径内影响到所有人的大范围攻击。他们为此做了大量的研究。我还记得我们讨论过当你被辣椒喷雾喷到时会发生什么。所以这就是为什么当时我想，好吧，我要拿一张纸巾，然后把它按在眼睛上。我们当时都在眨眼
outside in the parking lot. It's kind of like he's waiting, I think, for Jim to come out of the building, but Jim's not coming out of the building. Yeah, it's the end of the day and Jim and Karen are kind of, they're flirting, kind of making their plans, what they're going to do. And Roy gets tired of waiting in the parking lot and he comes on up inside. Yeah, he just, he bursts in, he yells for Jim, and Pam is like, oh, no. Well, did you notice Jim right away looks right to you? Like, oh, crap. Yeah. And then a lot happens. So Roy lunges at Jim. Jim just shoves Karen out of the way. He's like, I got to get Karen out of this line of danger. And right before Roy gets his hands on Jim, Dwight
而且一直在咳嗽。是的，我完全相信。好吧，安吉拉，关于这场戏我们有一个粉丝提问，来自11岁的莉拉·达诺。嗨，莉拉。还有来自凯瑟琳·M、安娜·C、斯蒂芬妮·T、克洛伊·J和汉娜·S的提问。他们都问，德怀特到底用什么喷了罗伊？因为我的意思是，显然我们并没有用辣椒喷雾去喷大卫·德曼。好吧，这确实是个好问题。我也很好奇。我想知道你是不是有什么昆蒂佩德或菲尔·谢伊的情报能告诉我们。我确实问过昆蒂佩德这件事，肯特说那其实是一个依云矿泉水瓶的喷雾器。哦，好吧，那各位，这演技可真够精湛的。对啊。你基本上就是被喷了点水雾而已。你基本上是去了一趟水疗，不过是个激烈、非常激烈的
pops up and just pepper sprays Roy in the face. I mean, Dwight doesn't just spray him, he like douses him with the whole container. And it clearly starts to affect everyone in the bullpen. Well, I remember Jeff Blitz talking to us about this. We had a whole conversation where he was like, listen, it's not just the person who gets hit that suffers the consequences of pepper spray going off. Like this, it's a, it's a miss that will affect people in a general radius. And they did a bunch of research on it. And I remember us talking about what happens when you get pepper sprayed. And so that's why I was like, okay, well, I'm going to pick up a tissue and I'm going to hold it to my eyes. And we were all blinking
水疗中心。没错，完全如此。好吧，我们还有其他人写信来问，尼蒂娅·G、亚伦·W、古斯塔沃·G、布丽安娜·L和卡莉·G。大家都问，在拍摄罗伊试图殴打吉姆的开场戏时，里面包含了多少武术编排，拍了多少条才最终完成。肯特告诉我，我们拍了——我还记得这个，安吉，大概拍了十几条罗伊冲进来的戏，我们拍下了所有人的反应，在甚至还没掏出喷雾之前，就把所有的动线都排练好了。然后我们只拍了实际喷射的那几条。所有的过程都有特技协调员在旁监督，我们的特技协调员叫鲍比·波特。我还记得鲍比·波特。对，他人太好了。好吧，你知道的，凯文和安吉拉当时不在。他们
and kind of coughing. Yeah, I believe it. Well, Angela, we had a fan question about this scene from Lila Dano, who is 11 years old. Hi, Lila. As well as from Catherine M. Anna C. Stephanie T. Chloe J. And Hannah S. They all asked, what did Dwight actually spray Roy with? Because I mean, obviously we didn't pepper spray David Denman. Well, that's a good question. And I was wondering it as well. I wonder if you had some kentipede or Phil Shea info for us. I did ask kentipede about this and Kent said that it was an Evian water bottle sprayer. Oh, well, that's some good acting then, you guys. Yeah. Yeah, you just got misted, basically. You basically went to the spa, aggressive and aggressive
不在场。哦，对哦。所以你们肯定记不得了。对，我们不在场。所以，但是，显然安吉拉对这个时刻有很多问题。我们一会儿就聊到这个。没错，她确实有。珍娜，现在我们进入这一集了，这绝对是我最喜欢的场景之一。迈克尔正通过免提电话和简通话。托比也在场。简问，托比在那儿吗？迈克尔说没有。然后托比就说，我就在这儿呢，简。于是托比向简更新了情况，说吉姆不打算起诉。他们打算放过罗伊。但因为罗伊要离开仓库了，达里尔现在想要加薪。他想要重新谈判他的工作待遇，对吧？对。而这接下来将被证明是个棘手的问题。然后简对迈克尔说，你打算
spa. Yes, exactly. Well, we had some other people write in, Nitya G. Aaron W. Gustavo G. Breanna L. And Carly G. All asked how much choreography went into filming the opening scene when Roy tries to punch Jim, how many takes were needed to get it done. And Kent told me that we did and I remember this, Ange, about a dozen takes of Roy just rushing in and we got everyone's reactions and we staged that all out before we ever even got out the spray. And then we only did a couple of takes where we actually sprayed. And everything was overseen by a stunt coordinator and our stunt coordinator's name was Bobby Porter. I remember Bobby Porter. Yeah, he was so sweet. Well, you know, Kevin and Angela aren't there. They're
是的，完全正确。还有其他一些观众给我们写信，比如Nitya G.、Aaron W.、Gustavo G.、Breanna L.以及Carly G.，他们都问在拍摄罗伊试图拳击吉姆的开场戏时，排练了多少编舞，拍了多少条才通过。肯特告诉我，而且我也记得，安吉，罗伊冲进来那场戏拍了大约十二条，我们拍下了每个人的反应，在拿出喷雾之前就把所有的动作都排练好了。然后我们只拍了几条真正喷喷雾的镜头。整个过程都有特技协调员监督，我们的特技协调员叫鲍比·波特。我记得鲍比·波特。是的，他人非常好。哦，你知道的，凯文和安吉拉当时不在那儿。他们不在那儿。
not there. Oh, that's right. So you would not have remembered that. No, we weren't there. So but, you know, obviously Angela has many questions about this moment. We'll get to that. Yes, she does. Jenna, now we're into the episode and this is just one of my favorite scenes. Michael is talking to Jan on speakerphone. Toby is there. Jan is like, is Toby there? Michael says no. And then Toby's like, I'm right here, Jan. And so Toby sort of updates Jan that Jim isn't going to press charges. They're going to let Roy go. But because Roy is leaving the warehouse, Daryl now wants a raise. He wants to renegotiate his job, right? Yeah. And this is going to prove to be problematic. And Jan says to Michael, are you going to
哦，对哦。所以你可能不记得了。不，我们当时不在。不过，你知道的，安吉拉显然对这个时刻有很多疑问。我们等会儿会聊到。是的，她会的。珍娜，现在我们进入了这一集，这也是我最喜欢的场景之一。迈克尔正在用免提和简通话。托比也在场。简问：托比在吗？迈克尔说不在。然后托比说：我就在这儿，简。于是托比向简更新了情况，说吉姆不打算起诉。他们打算放过罗伊。但是因为罗伊要离开仓库了，达里尔现在想要加薪。他想重新谈判他的工作，对吧？是的。这将会被证明是一个棘手的问题。简对迈克尔说，你打算
settle this? And this couplet of dialogue is one of my favorites. Sam, can you play it? You care of this? Yeppers. What did I tell you about Yeppers? I don't remember. I told you not to say it. Do you remember that? Yeesh.
解决这个问题？这段对话是我最喜欢的双关语之一。山姆，你能放一下吗？你来处理这个？耶珀斯。我跟你说过多少次别说耶珀斯了？我不记得了。我告诉过你不要说。你记得吗？天哪。
Jenna, I love this so much. I had to rewatch it a few times because this is a window into their relationship. And I love the Jan-Michael dynamic so much. How many times has he said Yeppers to her at home in their condo? How many times has he said it in the car or whatever they're doing? And she has had it with Yeppers. Yeppers is done. And she really doesn't want to have to say it again. How many times have I told you not to say Yeppers? Yeesh. Yeesh.
珍娜，我太喜欢这个了。我不得不重看了好几次，因为这是了解他们关系的窗口。我太喜欢简和迈克尔的动态了。他在家里的公寓里对她说过多少次耶珀斯？他在车里或其他任何他们做的事情中说过多少次？她对耶珀斯已经忍无可忍了。耶珀斯已经结束了。她真的不想再说了。我跟你说过多少次不要说耶珀斯？天哪。天哪。
Okay. Do you have a word that triggers you like that? Have you had a relationship where someone says something or a friendship? Oh, that's a good question. Do you? Well, I actually have had someone in my life, no names mentioned, that has said any who. Interesting. Any who. And let me tell you, any who repeated over and over, it can make you snap. I don't love the phrase brain fart. I don't. I don't love when people say, oh, I had a brain fart. Why? I don't know why.
好的。你有什么让你这样破防的词吗？你有没有过这样的感情经历，有人说了一些话，或者一段友情？哦，这是一个好问题。你有吗？嗯，我生命中确实有过这样一个人，不提名字，经常说“管他呢”。有趣。“管他呢”。我跟你说，一遍又一遍地说“管他呢”，真的会让人抓狂。我不喜欢“脑子短路”这个词。我不喜欢。我不喜欢人们说，哦，我脑子短路了。为什么？我不知道为什么。
I just don't love it. Well, listen, after this, Angela, Pam has this talking head. There's this kind of a series of talking heads. Pam says, you know, she doesn't want to be rude, but she would prefer not to comment on what happened. But it sucked. And at the end of that talking head, I feel like I smirk a little bit. Did you notice this? We had people write in about it. They were like, why does she kind of smirk at the end? She says it sucked. But is she smirking because she kind of liked it in some way? You guys, I'm Pam. And I was completely thrown by this performance choice. I don't know what I was doing there.
我就是不喜欢。听着，接下来，安吉拉，帕姆有一个访谈。有一系列这样的访谈。帕姆说，你知道，她不想表现得粗鲁，但她宁愿不评论发生了什么。但那太糟了。在那个访谈结束时，我觉得我笑得有点诡异。你注意到了吗？有人给我们写信提到了这个。他们说，为什么她最后那种表情？她说那太糟了。但她是不是因为某种程度上其实挺喜欢才笑的？各位，我是帕姆。我对这个表演选择完全摸不着头脑。我不知道我当时在干什么。
I mean, I sort of thought you were like trying to shrug it off. Like it sucked. You know how like when people are really uncomfortable, sometimes they smile. Yeah, I think that's what I was doing. Yeah, I certainly was not intending to make you think that Pam liked it. No, she was really uncomfortable by it. I think so uncomfortable that she doesn't even quite know how to relay it in the moment. It's like someone with a nervous laughter. Yeah, she's she's embarrassed. And we're going to see later in the episode, like she is she's truly embarrassed by this.
我是说，我有点以为你是想把它当回事儿。就像它太糟了。你知道当人们感到非常不自在时，有时他们会微笑。是的，我想我当时就是那个意思。是的，我当然不是想让大家觉得帕姆喜欢这个。不，她对此感到非常不自在。我觉得她不自在到甚至不知道当时该怎么转述。就像带着紧张的笑声。是的，她很尴尬。我们稍后会在剧集中看到，她对此感到非常尴尬。
I love this episode so much. And I feel like Mike sure really, really delivered on some dialogue. In particular, I loved when Jim was trying to think Dwight, he just wanted to thank him. And rain has great dialogue is Dwight. He he says, thank you, not necessary thus not accepted. Don't want it won't open it. Don't need it won't take it. He's got this really fun runner of how he is responding to Jim just simply trying to say thank you. Yeah. And Jim is going to keep trying to show his appreciation through this episode and Dwight will not have it. No.
我太喜欢这一集了。我觉得迈克·舒尔真的在台词上发挥得淋漓尽致。尤其是，我喜欢吉姆试图对德怀特说谢谢的时候，他只是想谢谢他。雷恩作为德怀特，台词太棒了。他说，谢谢，没必要，因此不接受。不想要，不打开，不需要，不接受。他有一个非常有趣的跑题桥段，讲他是如何回应吉姆简单的一句谢谢的。是的。吉姆在这集里会继续试图表达他的感激之情，而德怀特根本不买账。不。
Well, now Angela, we get to a scene that I love so much. And we got a lot of mail about like, okay, this is when Oscar gives Angela Roy's check and says Roy will be coming to pick this up later this afternoon. Kevin is really bummed that he missed the fight. And Angela says to Oscar. Yeah, I missed it too. Could you could you describe it? And so Oscar explains the fight and Dwight's heroism. How can we describe it? It has a real effect on Angela. I mean, guys, let's just call it out. She's totally turned on by this moment of like gallant
好吧，安吉拉，现在我们来到了一个我非常喜欢的场景。我们收到了很多邮件，关于——好吧，这就是奥斯卡把罗伊的支票给安吉拉，并说罗伊今天下午晚些时候会来取。凯文对错过这场打斗感到非常沮丧。安吉拉对奥斯卡说。是的，我也错过了。你能描述一下吗？于是奥斯卡描述了这场打斗和德怀特的英勇行为。我们怎么形容它呢？这对安吉拉产生了真正的影响。我是说，伙计们，让我们直说吧，她完全被德怀特这种英勇的
behavior by Dwight. And Roy, I don't know what's happening. The whole interaction clearly does it for her. You have to remember in season five, down the road, blood drive, we learn that Angela has had two men duel over her. Yeah. So she she has a thing for these dueling fellas. Mike, sure. I feel like always like to put my character in these really like, throws of emotion, whether she was incredibly upset or aroused or pissed off. Like, I feel like he liked to see her journey through that. Yes. Well, she's not a very emotionally showy person. And I think Mike liked to play with
行为给撩到了。罗伊，我不知道发生了什么。整个互动显然对她很管用。你得记住，在第五季的以后，献血车那一集，我们得知安吉拉曾有两个男人为她决斗。所以她对这种决斗的家伙情有独钟。迈克·舒尔，我觉得总是喜欢把我的角色置于这种强烈的情感波折中，无论是她超级沮丧、被撩到还是被气炸。我觉得他喜欢看她经历这些。是的。嗯，她不是一个情感外露的人。我想迈克喜欢利用这一点来发挥一下。
that a little bit. Well, we certainly had a lot of fun. I remember when we were doing this episode, having conversations with Jeff Blitz and Mike about how much of her hand would she tip, right? Like how much would she really show? And that was really fun to play around with. I did some takes where I reacted a little bit bigger, some a little smaller and just finding those nuances was so much fun for me as an actor. Well, we had a fan catch Angela from Madeline Weber and Greg Rodriguez. They said around four minutes 30 seconds, Angela appears to be rubbing a heart shaped necklace while Oscar
好吧，我们当然玩得很开心。我记得我们在拍这一集时，和杰夫·布里茨以及迈克讨论过，她会透露多少底牌，对吧？比如她会表现出多少真实情感？这玩起来真的很有趣。我拍了一些反应稍微大一点的镜头，也拍了一些稍微小一点的镜头，寻找那些细微差别对我作为演员来说太有趣了。好吧，我们有一个粉丝抓包安吉拉，来自马德琳·韦伯和格雷格·罗德里格斯。他们说在大约4分30秒时，当奥斯卡谈到德怀特的英雄行为时，安吉拉似乎在揉搓一条心形项链。
talks about Dwight's heroic actions. Do you think that this necklace was given to Angela by Dwight? Any thoughts on that, Angela? I have never thought about that. It was actually, if I remember, kind of like a tiny locket. And I remember when I was talking to Jeff Blitz about doing this scene, we talked about ways I might fidget a little to sort of show my emotion in this moment. And wardrobe had given me this necklace and I just began to play with it. I love the idea that it's a necklace that Dwight gave her though that adds a nice layer. I didn't think that through though. So, so that's a great idea.
你觉得这条项链是德怀特送给安吉拉的吗？对此有什么想法吗，安吉拉？我从没想过这个。实际上，如果我没记错的话，它有点像一个小小的挂坠。我记得当我和杰夫·布里茨谈论拍摄这场戏时，我们讨论了我可以做一些什么小动作来在这场戏中展现我的情绪。服装组给了我这条项链，我就开始摆弄它。不过我很喜欢这是德怀特送她的项链这个设定，这增加了一种很好的感觉。不过我之前没想过这个，所以，这真是个好主意。
Well, we had more questions Angela, more mail, please excuse me, but people want to know what Ellis Friedman said. Angela, you have all of these beautiful micro expressions on your face. How are you able to do that without doing too much? You do it a lot in this series, but you really get to shine in this episode. Oh, thank you. That is so nice. I remember when I got the script and I read Oscars retelling of it, you know, he's just telling it matter of factly what happened. But I did a little bit of homework as an actor. I wrote next to Oscars lines, what emotion that line made me think of. And then when I did the scene, I played through those emotions on my face.
好吧，安吉拉，我们还有更多问题，更多邮件，请原谅，但大家想知道埃利斯·弗里德曼说了什么。安吉拉，你的脸上有着所有这些美丽的微表情。你是怎么做到既不过度又表现出来的？你在整部剧中经常这样做，但在这一集里你真的大放异彩。哦，谢谢。太好了。我记得当我拿到剧本，读到奥斯卡对这件事的复述时，你知道，他只是客观地讲述发生了什么。但我作为演员做了一点功课。我在奥斯卡的台词旁边写下了那句台词让我想到的情绪。然后当我拍这场戏时，我在脸上演绎出了那些情绪。
And they were, you know, an example would be like surprise, nervousness, excited, embarrassed. So I would go through all of that and just kind of very subtly just do emotion. So as he said his lines, I was thinking of those emotions. I love that. That's so actory, Angela. I know. Oh, the actor there in me loves it. I love that. Well, Jenna, I could talk about these scenes because they were so juicy for me, but let's
它们是，你知道的，比如惊讶、紧张、兴奋、尴尬。所以我把这些都过了一遍，然后非常微妙地表现出情绪。所以当他说台词时，我在想着那些情绪。我太喜欢这个了。太有演员范儿了，安吉拉。我知道。哦，我内心的演员太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢了。好吧，珍娜，我本可以一直聊这些场景，因为它们对我很带感，但我们
move along. I want to talk about Michael's tactics that he has learned on Wikipedia, the best thing ever. And he's going to try them out on Jim, these negotiating tactics. Yes. Yes, he wants to roleplay. I mean, his ideas are you lean back, you mumble your words, you change location, surprise them. Guys, I looked up the art of negotiation online because of course I did. And? This is not how you do it. As we are learning, Michael's ways are not the way to do it. I
继续吧。我想谈谈迈克尔在维基百科上学到的战术，史上最棒的东西。他要在吉姆身上尝试这些谈判战术。是的，是的，他想进行角色扮演。我是说，他的想法是向后靠，喃喃自语，改变地点，给他们一个惊喜。伙计们，我在网上查了谈判的艺术，因为我当然会这么做。然后呢？这不是你该做的那样。正如我们所了解的那样，迈克尔的方法并不是正确的方法。我
will tell you, Jenna, there is so much to learn about negotiation. And the more I read, the more I realized what a horrible negotiator I have been in my career. It's a true art form. There's a whole theory of negotiation. I found it fascinating. But one of the things every sort of guide to negotiating has in common. And I, I read Forbes magazine, Business Insider, I went to the Harvard Law School website. And one of the things is they all say, do your homework, know your goals, listen, ask for what you want, right? And also one of the things they talk about is that a negotiation is not the same as conflict. You have to be willing to compromise or just say, no, if you don't like the offer. And I think I grew
要告诉你，珍娜，关于谈判有太多东西要学了。我读得越多，就越意识到我在自己的职业生涯中是一个多么糟糕的谈判者。这真的是一门艺术。有一整套谈判理论。我觉得这很着迷。但每种谈判指南都有一个共同点。我读了《福布斯》杂志、《商业内幕》，我去了哈佛法学院网站。其中一点是，他们都说，做你的功课，明确你的目标，倾听，说出你想要的，对吧？还有一点他们谈到的是，谈判不等同于冲突。如果你不喜欢这个报价，你必须愿意妥协或者直接说不。我想我成长于
up, Jenna, I don't know if it was just my family dynamic, but to negotiate something seemed confrontational and it's not. It's just expressing your needs and seeing if that other person or other company or whatever is willing to meet you halfway and you go back and forth. I found it really, it felt like a mini therapy session for me. Well, I remember I got some amazing advice from a very successful businessman right before I was getting ready to negotiate a big deal. And he said something that I've noticed, especially about women in negotiation, is they tend to negotiate with themselves first and they go in with where they've already compromised. So he's like, if you want three weeks vacation,
珍娜，我不知道是不是因为我的家庭环境，但谈判某事似乎具有对抗性，其实并不是。这只是表达你的需求，看看另一个人或另一家公司或其他什么人是否愿意各退一步，然后你们来回拉扯。我觉得这对我来说感觉像是一次微型治疗。好吧，在我准备敲定一笔大交易之前，我从一位非常成功的商人那里得到了一些惊人的建议。他说了一件我特别注意到的关于女性在谈判中的事情，那就是她们倾向于先和自己谈判，带着她们已经妥协的底线去谈。所以他说，如果你想要三周假期，
I see women especially talk themselves out of that or they think that's too much to ask for. So then they ask for two and then they get one. And he said, so my advice to you is go in there and really ask for what you want. Like don't negotiate with yourself first, just negotiate with the company. And I've never forgotten it. And it's not conflict. Negotiating is not conflict. It's totally different. It's going in there to be an advocate for yourself. Yes. I loved it. So anyway, there's tons of really great things online. And then I won't even get into this somehow. I ended up on a website that talked about the best and worst negotiations throughout history that involve countries
我看到女性尤其会自己说服自己放弃这个，或者她们认为要求太多了。于是她们要求两周，然后她们得到一周。所以他说，我对你的建议是，去那里真正争取你想要的。就像不要先和自己谈判，只跟公司谈判。我永远不会忘记这一点。这也不是冲突。谈判不是冲突。这完全不同。去那里是为了成为你自己的代言人。是的。我太喜欢了。总之，网上有大量非常棒的内容。然后我甚至不想深入探讨这个，不知怎的，我最终进入了一个网站，上面讨论了历史上涉及国家和政策的最佳和最糟谈判。
and policy. And it was fascinating. Well, I need to know about that. I know for later, for later. This is a big episode. Well, now Angela, we go back to the annex. And Toby is clearly taking statements on what happened. And he is taking Dwight's statement. In the meantime, Ryan and Kelly are on the other side of the partition and they are eavesdropping and they start getting in a fight because Ryan is like, I wonder what I would have done if I'd been there. And Kelly's like, I know exactly what you would have done because when that kid dropped their shake on me, when we were on the ferris wheel, you just laughed. And you didn't stand up for me. And oh, this starts a whole thing.
太迷人了。好吧，我得了解一下这个。我知道，留着以后用，留着以后用。这是一个重要的单集。好吧，现在安吉拉，我们回到附属办公室。托比显然在记录发生的事情，他正在记录德怀特的证词。与此同时，瑞安和凯利在隔断的另一边，他们在偷听，然后他们开始吵架，因为瑞安说，我不知道如果我在那里我会怎么做。凯利说，我完全知道你会怎么做，因为当那个小孩在摩天轮上把奶昔洒在我身上时，你只是笑。你根本没有为我挺身而出。哦，这引发了一连串的事情。
Ryan and Kelly remind me of that SNL sketch, the Bickersons. Do you remember that? The couple that gets really awkwardly fights at the dinner table and then makes out in the hallway at a party. And they're doing all of this behind Toby. And he has a brilliant line where he says, I don't think Michael intended to punish me by putting Ryan back here with Kelly. But if he did intend that, wow, genius. Well, now at seven minutes, 40 seconds, guys, Daryl has arrived to negotiate with Michael. And Michael is already trying out his tactics. He's going to change the location at the last minute, but then he's changes it back. And then they sit in silence. Yes. And then he won't speak first. Oh, that
瑞安和凯利让我想起了那个周六夜现场的小品《比克森一家》。你还记得吗？那对夫妻在餐桌上尴尬地大吵大闹，然后在派对的走廊里热吻。他们就在托比背后做这一切。他有一句精彩的台词，他说，我不认为迈克尔把瑞安弄回这里跟凯利在一起是存心惩罚我。但如果他是存心的，哇，简直是个天才。好吧，现在到了7分40秒，伙计们，达里尔已经来和迈克尔谈判了。迈克尔已经在尝试他的战术了。他要在最后一分钟改变地点，但随后他又改回来了。然后他们相对无言地坐着。是的。然后他坚决不先开口。哦，那
was so awkward. They sat there for so long. I love Craig Robinson in these scenes. He's so still, right? He's just sitting there. And it's so confuses Michael, like Michael does not understand. So finally he says, I'm declining to speak first. Yeah, he can't take it anymore. And Daryl's like, All right, I'll start. Well, I think Daryl, if you guys read about negotiation theory, he has come with a clear vision of what he wants. And there's no BS. He's very upfront. And Michael is doing all this weird stuff and cannot understand that Daryl is not thrown by it. And it's at this moment when Daryl says, Michael, are you wearing a woman's suit? I think he says, Are you wearing lady clothes? That's right.
太尴尬了。他们坐在那里那么久。我喜欢这些场景中的克雷格·罗宾逊。他太安静了，对吧？他就坐在那里。这把迈克尔弄糊涂了，就像迈克尔完全不理解。所以最后他说，我拒绝先说话。是的，他再也受不了了。达里尔说，好吧，我先开始。好吧，我想达里尔，如果你们读过谈判理论，他带着对想要的清晰愿景来的。而且没有废话。他非常直率。迈克尔在做所有这些奇怪的事情，却无法理解达里尔根本没有被他吓到。就在这一刻，达里尔说，迈克尔，你穿的是女装吗？我想他说的是，你穿的是女士衣服吗？没错。
And Michael's like, What are you talking about? Michael goes on to tell this talking head that I love. He said he found a suit in a bin. And there were a lot of people and they were rifling through things like crazy. And I don't know, maybe the suit is bisexual. It's it's made by mysterious. And there's buttons on the wrong side. Maybe that's the mystery. It's European. Okay, it's a European cut. He just is like, rambling all this stuff. And Jenna, I love the idea that Michael went to some crazy day after Thanksgiving, Black Friday craziness at some like department store and was rifling through a bin. Yeah. And he was really proud of it. I think he really did think he had bought like a European suit
迈克尔说，你在说什么？迈克尔接着在一个访谈中说了一段我很喜欢的话。他说他在一个旧衣堆里找到了一套西装。有很多人在那里疯狂地翻找东西。我不知道，也许这套西装是双性恋的？它是神秘制造的。纽扣在错误的一侧。也许这就是神秘之处。它是欧洲风格的。好吧，它是欧洲剪裁。他就是一直在胡言乱语。珍娜，我很喜欢迈克尔去某个疯狂的感恩节后黑色星期五疯狂大促销的百货公司，在一个旧衣堆里疯狂翻找的画面。是的。而且他为此感到非常自豪。我想他真的以为自己打折买了一套欧洲西装。
on sale. Well, he comes out into the bullpen and he's like, Pam, Pam, will you please tell everyone that this is not a woman's suit? And Pam is like, Oh my gosh, it doesn't have any pockets. And then when Steve turns around and like shows how he can't put his hands in his back pockets, it makes me laugh so hard. Yeah. And Phyllis is like, and it has shoulder pads. Well, let me just say, Angela, this scene points out something that has been a pet peeve of mine for a long time, more than a pet peeve. So if you'll excuse me, I need to get my soap box and I'm going to be there for a second. I was I was going to say, are you about to stand up on a soap box? I am. I want to discuss the lack of adequate pockets
好吧，他走到办公区，他说，帕姆，帕姆，请你告诉大家这不是女装，好吗？帕姆说，哦天哪，它连口袋都没有。然后当史蒂夫转过身来，展示他怎么把手放不进后口袋时，我笑得前仰后合。是的。菲利丝说，它还有垫肩。好吧，让我说，安吉拉，这个场景指出了一件困扰我很久的事，比心头大患还要严重的事。所以请原谅，我需要搬出我的肥皂箱，我要在那儿站一会儿。我本来想说，你这是要站上肥皂箱吗？我是。我想讨论女性服装上缺乏足够的口袋。好吧，我本来就知道你这样。继续。
on women's clothing. Okay, I know this about you already. Go. Well, first of all, I did a deep dive on pockets because it has bothered me for a long time. You know, Angela, I've had back problems. So it is not comfortable or practical for me to carry a purse. So I had this idea. I'm going to just carry a wallet in my pocket. Men do it all the time. Why can't I do that? But whenever I would try to put like my phone or a wallet in my pockets, they pop out when I sit down. And here is why. Are you ready? I don't know if I'm ready. Bring it. So in the beginning, all clothing was made without pockets and everyone, men and women carried around a little pouch with their money and belongings. If you've ever
首先，我对口袋进行了一次深入研究，因为它困扰我很久了。你知道的，安吉拉，我有背部问题。所以背着钱包对我来说既不舒服也不实用。所以我有个主意。我只要把钱包放在口袋里就行了。男人一直都这么做。为什么我不能那样做？但每当我试图把手机或钱包放进我的口袋时，当我坐下时它们就会弹出来。原因在这里。你准备好了吗？我不知道我准备好了没。放马过来吧。所以在最初，所有的衣服都是没有口袋的，每个人，无论男女，都随身带着一个小袋子来装钱和随身物品。如果你看过《草原小屋》，你就会看到。
watched Little House on the Prairie, you've seen it. Both Ma and Pa, they both carry around a little pouch. Yes. All right. And what was it was a pouch called? I don't know. It was just a pocket pouch. Oh, that's so interesting. Because I know my mom will still sometimes say, will you get me my pocket book? Yes, because your pocket was not a thing that was sewn on you. It was a thing you carried. Oh, that makes very... I always wondered where pocket book came from. Okay, go on. I'm interested. Let's do it. All right. So about 400 years ago, they started sewing pockets into men's clothing, but not women's clothing. Why not? Well, some historians think that it was a way to keep women sort of powerless. Like
玛和帕，他们都随身带着一个小袋子。是的。好吧，那个袋子叫什么名字？我不知道。它就叫口袋袋。哦，太有趣了。因为我知道我妈妈有时还是会说，你能帮我拿下我的口袋书吗？是的，因为你的口袋不是缝在衣服上的东西。那是一个你随身携带的东西。哦，那太有意思了。我一直很好奇“pocket book”这个词是怎么来的。好吧，继续。我很感兴趣。我们继续。好吧。大约400年前，人们开始把口袋缝在男人的衣服上，但没有缝在女人的衣服上。为什么不呢？好吧，一些历史学家认为，这是让女性保持某种无权力状态的一种方式。比如
you couldn't hide keys or money or do business. Like your pocket was on the outside of you. You were more vulnerable. Okay. Okay. Less secure. Got it. But then in the late 1800s, there was a movement called the Rational Dress Society. Jenna, are these your people? These are your people, the Rational Dress Society. Well, listen to what these women did. What? Their goal was to quote, dress for comfort and health. Yeah. These are definitely your people. I know. These women are definitely in drawstring pants today. I'll tell you that. Oh, they are. Well, back then, their main goal was to get women to abandon the corset because it was literally unhealthy to wear a corset. And they also really pushed for
你不能藏钥匙或钱，也不能做生意。你的口袋在你的外面。你更加脆弱。好吧。好吧。不够安全。明白了。但后来在19世纪末，有一个名为理性着装协会的运动。珍娜，这些人是你的同类吗？这是你们的人，理性着装协会。好吧，听听这些女性做了什么。什么？她们的目标是引用，“为舒适和健康着装”。是的。这些绝对是你的同类。我知道。这些女性今天绝对穿着抽绳裤。我敢保证。哦，她们是的。好吧，当时，她们的主要目标是让女性放弃束腰，因为穿束腰束身衣在生理上是不健康的。她们还大力推动
women to be able to wear trousers with pockets without stigma. Love it. All right. Eventually in 1920, Coco Chanel started sewing pockets into women's jackets, but it was not until the 1970s when women regularly started wearing jeans that we finally had pockets on a regular basis, Angela. That is crazy to me because, I mean, the 70s are not that long ago. Someone sitting right here might have been born in the 70s. I was born in the 70s. I know. And that's when, like, ladies started having more pockets. That's crazy. Well, they started having pockets, Angela, but they weren't great because pockets on women's clothing are either sewn shut in the example of Michael's suit. What am I supposed to do with that? What am
女性能够穿着带口袋的长裤而不受污名化。太棒了。好吧。最终在1920年，可可·香奈儿开始把口袋缝进女式夹克中，但直到20世纪70年代，当女性开始经常穿牛仔裤时，我们才终于有了常规的口袋，安吉拉。这对我来说太疯狂了，因为，我的意思是，70年代并没有那么久远。此时此刻坐在里的人可能就出生在70年代。我是70年代出生的。我知道。也就是从那时起，女士们才开始有更多的口袋。这太疯狂了。好吧，她们开始有口袋了，安吉拉，但它们并不好，因为女装上的口袋要么像迈克尔的西装那样被假缝死。我该拿它怎么办？
I doing with a faux pocket? Yeah. Or they are proportionally smaller than men's pockets. Oh, oh, that's so true. I cannot fit my cell phone in my pants pocket. It falls out of the side. It doesn't fit. Well, Angela, I'll tell you what, I read a report that tested 80 pairs of pockets on both men's and women's blue jeans, all with a waist size of 32. So wait, same size pants. Same size pants. So you can't say, oh, the pockets are smaller because women's pants are smaller than men's pants. No. They are proportionally smaller. On average, women's front pockets were 48% smaller and 6.5% more narrow. Why? I don't know. I mean, I get it if, like, it's like a smaller, like, style. You know what I mean?
我拿一个假口袋怎么办？是的。或者它们在比例上比男人的口袋小。哦，哦，这太真实了。我的手机塞不进我的裤子口袋。它会从侧面掉出来。塞不进去。好吧，安吉拉，我告诉你，我读过一份报告，测试了男女蓝色牛仔裤上的80对口袋，所有腰围都是32。所以等等，同样尺码的裤子。同样尺码的裤子。所以你不能说，哦，口袋小是因为女裤比男裤小。不。它们的比例更小。平均而言，女性的前口袋小了48%，窄了6.5%。为什么？我不知道。我的意思是，我懂的，如果，比如，它是一个更小的款式。你知道我的意思吗？
But on two pairs of jeans that are made the same. You know, Angela, here's my thing. Okay. Am I getting out your soap box? My soap box is out. Okay, get on it. Here's what I want to say, Angela. I think we all know that women do not get paid the same as men, even if they're doing the same job. And we also know now that our pockets don't hold as much. I just think we need bigger pockets and bigger paychecks. Chutching. Can I get my chutching? Equal pay for equal pockets. Hashtag it, everyone. Hashtag, Jenna, I liked the history of pockets. I found that fascinating. Yeah, thank you very much. You're welcome. I'm passionate about pockets and Angela, I'm also passionate about high heel shoes and
但在两条剪裁相同的牛仔裤上。你知道吗，安吉拉，我的看法是。好吧。我是要把你的肥皂箱搬出来吗？我的肥皂箱已经搬出来了。好吧，上去吧。我想说的是，安吉拉，我想我们都知道女性的薪水和男性不一样，即使她们做的是同样的工作。我们也知道现在的口袋装不了那么多东西。我只是觉得我们需要更大的口袋和更多的薪水。叮咚。我能有我的叮咚吗？同工同酬，同量同袋。大家加上标签。标签，珍娜，我喜欢口袋的历史。我觉得这太迷人了。是的，非常感谢。不客气。我对口袋充满热情，安吉拉，我也对高跟鞋充满热情。
why we shouldn't wear them, but I'll save that for another episode. Okay. Well, you know, Michael is just so embarrassed and devastated. You know, he's not, he thought he was on top of things with this negotiation and this has really thrown him. Yeah, he said he made one mistake. You can't make any mistakes in negotiating, but he wore one. But he made one mistake, wearing women's clothing. Yes. And now, Jenna, this scene takes us to the kitchen and I have labeled this scene at 11 minutes, 15 seconds. Kevin, the shit stirrer. Yes. I mean, Kevin, listen to what he says to Karen in front of Stanley and Angela. Kevin says, so Karen, how do you feel that Roy tried to kick your boyfriend's ass over another
为什么我们不应该穿高跟鞋，但我把这个留到下一集再说。好吧。你知道，迈克尔只是太尴尬、太崩溃了。你知道，他不是，他以为自己这次谈判稳操胜券，而这真的让他大受打击。是的，他说他犯了一个错误。谈判中不能犯任何错误，但他偏偏穿了一套。但他犯了一个错误，穿了女装。是的。现在，珍娜，这个场景把我们带到了厨房，我把11分15秒的这个场景标记为。凯文，这个挑事精。是的。我是说，凯文，听听他对凯伦在斯坦利和安吉拉面前说了什么。凯文说，所以凯伦，罗伊试图为了另一个
woman? I mean, yeah, Kevin, sit down, Kevin, you need to sit down. But then Angela is like, you know, I wasn't there. I mean, what happened? I wasn't there because she wants Karen to tell her the story. She cannot get enough. I remember talking to Phil Shea about what I should be eating in this scene. And we thought it would be kind of funny if she's eating grapes. It's a very sort of like, like Renaissance moment for her. The lady eating grapes being titillated by a story. So now we go back to Michael's office. He and Darrell are still negotiating and Darrell makes a very compelling argument for why he deserves a raise. Yeah, he said he's picking up Roy Slack. I mean, that that is so legitimate. But Jenna, I have
女人踢你男朋友的屁股，你觉得怎么样？我是说，是的，凯文，坐下吧，凯文，你需要坐下。但随后安吉拉说，你知道，我当时不在场。我的意思是，发生了什么？我不在场，因为她想让凯伦把事情的经过告诉她。她听不够。我记得跟菲尔·谢伊谈过我在这场戏里应该吃什么。我们觉得如果她吃葡萄会挺搞笑的。这有点像她的文艺复兴时刻。贵妇吃着葡萄，被八卦故事挑逗着。现在我们回到迈克尔的办公室。他和达里尔仍在谈判，达里尔就他为什么配得上加薪提出了非常令人信服的论据。是的，他说他在收拾罗伊留下的烂摊子。我的意思是，这太合情合理了。但珍娜，我
to tell you, there is a fantastic blooper moment. If you go to the bloopers on YouTube, you know, Michael is doing that weird mumble tack that we're talking about. Yeah, yeah. And there's some great bloopers of Steve and Craig just cracking up. I love that. Well, I don't know if you noticed in the background over Darrell's shoulder, Pam is not at reception. Do you know why? Oh, that's a good catch because she's in the break room. Yeah, she's in the break room and she's experiencing major heartbreak in the break room. Lady, I titled this scene despair in the break room. Well, despair. Well, I thought it was so heartbreaking. I felt it warranted a little musical intro. Sam, could you play Heartbreak in the Break
必须告诉你，有一个非常棒的失误镜头。如果你去看YouTube上的失误花絮，你知道，迈克尔在用我们谈论的那个奇怪的含糊不清的腔调说话。是的，是的，有一些史蒂夫和克雷格大笑的精彩失误镜头。我太喜欢了。好吧，我不知道你有没有注意到在达里尔肩膀后面的背景里，帕姆不在前台。你知道为什么吗？哦，这是一个好抓包，因为她在休息室。是的，她在休息室，她在休息室经历着严重的心碎。女士，我把这个场景命名为休息室里的绝望。好吧，绝望。好吧，我觉得这太令人心碎了。我觉得这值得一段小小的音乐开场。山姆，你能播放乔希·康普顿的《休息室里的心碎》吗？
Room by Josh Compton? There's a cold one that blows through the hallways in Cubic Coral. Add a lonely old phantom of sorrow as Granton rolls in. And there's a sad secretary who's mourning the loss of a friend. It's the oldest of stories, heartbreak in the break room again. The white if you're near, the lender in ear, and a jacket to shoulder the pain. She's not PMSing, it's something more pressing, heartbreak in the break room again. Yeah, well, ain't that the truth? Heartbreak again. Now, Jenna, this scene when I watched it, I did think of Dwight and Angela scenes just in the fact of the staging. Yeah. He doesn't look at you. His back is towards you the whole time. Yes. Yeah. And Pam gets pretty
一阵寒风吹过立方体走廊，当格兰顿滚滚而来时，留下一道孤独的悲伤幽灵。还有一个哀悼着失去朋友的悲伤秘书。这是最古老的故事，休息室里再次心碎。如果你在附近，借给耳朵，还有一副肩膀可以分担痛苦。她不是经前综合症，而是更迫切的事情，休息室里再次心碎。是的，难道这不是真的吗？再次心碎。现在，珍娜，当我看到这个场景时，我确实想到了德怀特和安吉拉的场景，仅仅是在舞台布景方面。是的。他没有看着你。他的背一直对着你。是的。是的，帕姆在这里变得相当
vulnerable here. She's really trying to connect. She says, I'm really sorry. It's over with Roy. And Jim is doing that thing where he's like, Oh, yeah, no, I'm sure it's fine. I mean, come on, you guys will get back together again. I'm sure. Yeah. Oh, he's being so cold. So cold. And he doesn't believe her. That's the thing. I really believe that he doesn't believe her. He's like, we'll see. You guys were good together. You'll probably figure it out. And she's just like, Oh, yeah. Oh, she just feels so bad, so embarrassed. And you know, Jim has just been down this road too many times with her. I think he's really, really trying to move on. And that's why he's behaving this way in the scene. He's like,
脆弱。她真的很想建立连接。她说，我真的很遗憾。一切都和罗伊结束了。吉姆正在做那种事情，他说，哦，是的，不，我相信一切都好。我是说，拜托，你们俩以后还会复合的。我确信。是的。哦，他太冷漠了。太冷漠了。他不相信她。这就是重点。我真的相信他不相信她。他说，我们走着瞧。你们俩以前挺好的。你们可能会弄明白的。她只是说，哦，是的。哦，她觉得自己太糟糕了，太尴尬了。你知道，吉姆已经和她一起走过这条路太多次了。我觉得他真的，真的在努力继续生活。这就是他在这一场戏中表现得像这样的原因。他说，
I can't do this again. Yeah, well, I think he's probably frustrated with himself that he, he let himself get to a place emotionally where he could see them together again. And in Phyllis's wedding, that was just crushed. Yeah. And he's just not going to put himself out there like that. It's too much drama. So much drama. You know, I get it. I get why he's like, you know what? I'm not going there. Yeah. Well, then in the next scene, we find out that Michael hasn't had a raise in 14 years. He's never been given a raise ever. Ever. And, and, and he shows Daryl his pay stub. And Daryl was like, Oh my God, any wonder they're not going to give me a raise? Look what they're paying you. You've got to ask
我不能再这样做了。是的，好吧，我想他可能对自己感到沮丧，因为他，他让自己在情感上达到了一个可以看到他们再次在一起的境地。而在菲利丝的婚礼上，那个幻想彻底破灭了。是的。他再也不会让自己陷入那种境地了。太多抓马了。太多抓马了。你知道，我懂。我懂为什么他说，你知道吗？我才不蹚这浑水。是的。好吧，在接下来的场景中，我们发现迈克尔已经14年没加过薪了。他从来没有加过薪，一次都没有。而且，而且，他向达里尔展示了他的工资单。达里尔说，哦，天哪，难怪他们不给我加薪？看看他们付给你的工资。你得要求
for a raise. Yeah. And he convinces Michael to call Jan and ask for a raise. But before Michael hits up Jan, we find Jim and Karen in the kitchen. Yeah. Jim is eating his carrots. 15 minutes, 22 seconds. Bag of carrots. Bag of carrots. And you know, he wants Karen's advice about how he can thank Dwight. And she was like, Well, are you feeling guilty for all those pranks you pulled on him? Jim's like, Yeah, maybe that's it. And she says, Okay, we'll go sell some paper so we can go on a trip. Yeah, focus on work. She's so practical. I know. He's like, Dang it. I don't want practicality. I want to play pranks with Pam, but I can't because she keeps breaking my heart. Yes. Well, finally, Michael does
加薪。是的。他劝迈克尔打电话给简要求加薪。但在迈克尔联系简之前，我们在厨房找到了吉姆和凯伦。是的。吉姆在吃他的胡萝卜。15分22秒。一袋胡萝卜。一袋胡萝卜。你知道，他想征求凯伦的建议，看他如何感谢德怀特。她问，好吧，你是在为那些你对他的恶作剧感到内疚吗？吉姆说，是的，也许就是这样。她说，好吧，去卖纸吧，这样我们就可以去旅行了。是的，专注于工作。她太务实了。我知道。他说，该死。我不要务实。我想和帕姆一起恶作剧，但我不能，因为她一直在伤我的心。是的。好吧，最后迈克尔确实
pick up the phone, right? He's like, I'm going to call Jan and I'm going to ask for a raise. And he's got Jan on speakerphone and Daryl is supervising. He's kind of like going to be his support, right? His coach. Yeah. And Jan tells Michael the only way they can discuss a possible raise is if he comes in person by five o'clock, and he has to bring Toby. And he says, Toby is the worst human being I've ever known. Michael says, I'm bringing Daryl. And she's like, Michael, we need someone from HR. So now the three of them are going to be on this weird road trip. In the meantime, Angela still wants to hear this story, guys. He's not done. And she asked Creed. Here's Creed's version. Ready? Yes. Big Fella comes
拿起了电话，对吧？他说，我要打电话给简，我要要求加薪。他把简开了免提，达里尔在监督。他有点像在做他的支持者，对吧？他的教练。是的。简告诉迈克尔，他们讨论可能的加薪的唯一方法是他必须在5点钟亲自来，而且他必须带上托比。他说，托比是我见过的最糟糕的人类。迈克尔说，我带达里尔去。简说，迈克尔，我们需要一个来自人力资源部的人。现在他们三个人要进行这次奇怪的公路旅行。与此同时，安吉拉仍然想听这个故事，伙计们。他还没讲完。她去问克里德。这是克里德的版本。准备好了吗？是的。大块头大约在
in about 1130 at night, screaming. Jim stole his car. Big Fella pulls out a sock full of nickels. Shrewt grabs hairspray and a lighter. So insane. So insane. Angela's like, you're useless. Then she goes to Kelly. And Kelly's like, you know, I think Toby wrote a whole report about it. And Angela's like, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. And she goes and steals the report. Yes. I mean, what is she up to? And I have to point out we haven't talked about it. This is a very classic Angela Martin hairdo. Yes, I was going to ask you, it looks like the Angela Martin braid, but also it's a ponytail. I think it's the headband braid ponytail version. I will tell you, it's all my hair. That is not a hairpiece. Kim Ferry,
晚上11点半进来，尖叫着。吉姆偷了他的车。大块头掏出一只塞满五分硬币的袜子。施鲁特抓起发胶和打火机。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。安吉拉说，你真没用。然后她去找凯利。凯利说，你知道，我觉得托比为此写了一整份报告。安吉拉说，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。她去把报告偷了过来。是的。我是说，她到底想干什么？我必须指出，我们还没聊过这个。这是一个非常经典的安吉拉·马丁发型。是的，我正想问你，这看起来像安吉拉·马丁式的编发，但同时它也是一个马尾辫。我觉得这是发箍编发马尾辫版本。我得告诉你，这全都是我自己的头发。那不是假发片。金·费里，
the master of hair, she was able to separate a little piece, do this braid over, pin it into a ponytail. And, and that's all my hair, guys. I love it. Did it give you a headache? It didn't. Those did not give me a headache. It was more like the severe buns. Yeah. Yeah. Well, listen, we're about to hit the road with Michael and Daryl and Toby. But before we do, let's take a break and we'll be right back. All right. So now Toby and Daryl and Michael are in the car. This is hilarious pairing. No one's comfortable. He's like, you're comfortable. No, you comfortable. No. And then Daryl's like saying, maybe I'll crash in New York for the night. And, and Toby's like, how
发型大师，她能够分出一小撮头发，做这个编发，把它别进马尾辫里。而且，这全都是我自己的头发，伙计们。我太喜欢了。这让你头疼吗？没有。那些没有让我头疼。更像是那些紧绷的发髻。是的。是的。好吧，听着，我们马上要和迈克尔、达里尔和托比一起上路了。但在我们这样做之前，先休息一下，我们马上回来。好吧。现在托比、达里尔和迈克尔在车里。这是一个搞笑的组合。没有人觉得舒服。他说，你舒服吗？不，你舒服吗？不。然后达里尔说，也许我今晚在纽约过夜。然后，托比说，我们怎么
will we get back? He's like, you could stay. And then, but Michael's not in fight. I know. I love this odd grouping of people. This is one of my favorite things. This feels very Mike sure to me as well. He loved to team up odd characters. Angela, I have to say bring up the movie rush hour in the car, right? And this made me think of the movie speed. Stay with me here. Do you remember a few podcasts back? You were like line for line quoting speed. And I was like, when is the last time you watch speed? And you were like three days ago pop quiz asshole. There it is. Well, I got that in my head. And I was like, huh, maybe I should watch speed. Did you watch speed? Angela, it is so good. Everybody watch
回去？他说，你可以留下来。然后，但是迈克尔不在状态。我知道。我喜欢这种奇怪的人物组合。这让我觉得非常像迈克尔·舒尔的风格。他喜欢把奇怪的角色组合在一起。安吉拉，我不得不提一下车里的电影《尖峰时刻》，对吧？这让我想起了电影《生死时速》。听我说。你还记得几个播客前吗？你一直在逐字引用《生死时速》。我说，你上次看《生死时速》是什么时候？你说三天前。现场测试，混蛋。就是这样。好吧，我脑子里有了这个想法。我想，哼，也许我应该看看《生死时速》。你看了《生死时速》吗？安吉拉，太棒了。大家都去看
speed. Okay. Cano Reeves, Sandra Bullock, Jeff Daniels. I mean, you guys, this movie has everything. It's action, romance, friendship. I mean, and it's peak Keanu Reeves hotness. It is peak Keanu Reeves hotness. Well, Angela, I'll tell you what, I enjoyed speed so much that then I watched point break. Oh, oh, wait, surfs up bro. Yes, Johnny Utah. Are you kidding me, Utah? Let me tell you this. You thought that speed was peak Keanu Reeves hotness. But in point break, he starts in the rain, and he ends in the rain. Okay. He's, it's a beautiful, Catherine Bigelow directed it. Yeah. Again, there is in the movie point break, there is a five minute, at least five minute foot chase through people's backyards and
《生死时速》。好吧。基努·里夫斯，桑德拉·布洛克，杰夫·丹尼尔斯。我是说，伙计们，这部电影应有尽有。有动作、浪漫、友情。我是说，这是基努·里夫斯颜值巅峰。这是基努·里夫斯颜值巅峰。好吧，安吉拉，我告诉你，我很享受《生死时速》，以至于我又看了《惊爆点》。哦，哦，等待，冲浪好兄弟。是的，强尼·犹他。你在开玩笑吗，犹他？我告诉你这个。你以为《生死时速》是基努·里夫斯的颜值巅峰。但在《惊爆点》里，他从雨中开始，在雨中结束。好吧。它是，这是一部美丽的电影，凯瑟琳·毕哥罗导演的。是的。同样，在电影《惊爆点》中，有一场至少五分钟的追逐戏，穿过人们的后院
houses and jumping over fences. When do you see that anymore in movies? I absolutely love both these movies. So I have decided that to get me through the rest of 2020, I will become a Keanu Reeves film aficionado. And I think I'm going to start next on the John Wick movies, which I've never seen. Well, Josh has seen the John Wick movies. He told me they might be too violent for me. But I love Keanu Reeves. You know I love him. Yeah. And I have seen pretty much all of his movies, but maybe I'll watch John Wick with you. Let's watch John Wick and we'll get back to each other. We're going to have to go into some Bill and Ted's, you know, the new one just came out and my friend Aaron Hayes got to
和房子，跳过栅栏。你现在在电影里还能看到这种戏吗？我绝对喜欢这两部电影。所以我决定，为了让我度过2020年剩下的时间，我将成为一名基努·里夫斯电影发烧友。我想我接下来要从《疾速追杀》系列开始看，我从来没看过。好吧，乔希看过《疾速追杀》系列。他告诉我，对我来说可能太暴力了。但我爱基努·里夫斯。你知道我爱他。是的。我几乎看过他所有的电影，但也许我会和你一起看《疾速追杀》。让我们看《疾速追杀》，然后我们再交流。我们得去看看《比箭和特德历险记》，你知道，新的一部刚刚上映，我的朋友亚伦·海斯亲到了
kiss Keanu Reeves. Well, you're going to need to get some information on that and bring that to the podcast. Aaron was in Hot Wives of Vegas with me on Hulu. When did she kiss Keanu Reeves? In Bill and Ted's second one. Oh. What about a Walk in the Clouds? What about that one? Yeah, I don't know. I don't know. I mean, we have a lot to do. Don't get me started on The Matrix, one of my favorite movies ever. Well, I don't need to rewatch those because I've seen them so many times, but I will because I want to. There is no spoon. Yeah. Oh, I'm so excited. I had no idea you went down that. It's what I'm doing now. Oh my God, they play football on the beach. Are you kidding me? All right. So the
基努·里夫斯。好吧，你需要获取一些关于这方面的信息，并把它带到播客中。亚伦和我一起出演了Hulu上的《维加斯辣妻》。她什么时候亲的基努·里夫斯？在《比箭和特德历险记》第二部里。哦。《漫步在云端》呢？那部怎么样？是的，我不知道。我不知道。我是说，我们有很多事要做。别让我开始聊《黑客帝国》，我最喜欢的电影之一。好吧，我不需要重温那些，因为我看过太多次了，但我会的，因为我想看。没有汤匙。是的。哦，我太兴奋了。我不知道你走进了那个领域。这就是我现在在做的事情。哦，天哪，他们在沙滩上踢足球。你在开玩笑吗？好吧。所以
guys eventually they get to New York, they get to Dunder Mifflin and we find Michael sitting in the lobby and he looks over to the woman sitting next to him and she is wearing the same suit. You know, Jenna, I looked up how many times does Michael Scott wear women's clothing by accident? This is going to be a recurring thing. It is? Yes. Do I not remember this? Okay. In launch party, he has on a shirt that's way too tight and the consensus is that it was probably a woman's shirt. Okay. And then in nepotism, Aaron mentions that the pants Michael had that she had to return to Talbott's or something. So clearly he's bought some women's suits repeatedly and he says he won't make that mistake again. Well,
伙计们最终到了纽约，他们来到了邓德米夫林，我们发现迈克尔坐在大厅里，他看着坐在他旁边的那个女人，她穿着同一套西装。你知道，珍娜，我查了一下迈克尔·斯科特因意外穿女装穿了多少次？这将是一个经常发生的梗。是吗？是的。我不记得这个了吗？好吧。在发布派对那一集，他穿着一件太紧的衬衫，大家的共识是那可能是一件女式衬衫。好吧。然后在家族任职那一集，亚伦提到迈克尔有几条裤子，她不得不退回到塔尔伯特服装店什么的。所以很明显他多次购买了女式西装，并且他说他不会再犯这个错误了。好吧，
we got some mail. We had some questions from Maruna T, Breanna K, Megan S, Rachel Hayes and Dan Salomon. They said, was Steve really wearing a woman's suit or was it custom made for him? So, Ange, I reached out to Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer. Awesome. Here is what she told me. She said it really was a lady's suit. She did not have time to sew something from scratch because they would have had to also sew a matching suit for the woman in the lobby. So here's what she did. She said the first thing she did was try to find a woman's suit that would fit Steve and then hope that she could buy an identical one to fit the woman. So she went to stores with a measuring tape looking for a jacket
我们收到了一些邮件。我们有一些来自鲁娜·T、布里安娜·K、梅根·S、雷切尔·海斯和丹·萨洛蒙的问题。他们说，史蒂夫真的是在穿女装，还是那是为他定制的？所以，安吉拉，我联系了我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特。太棒了。这是她告诉我。她说那真的是一套女式西装。她没有时间从头缝制一套，因为他们还得为大厅里的那个女人缝制一套配套的西装。所以她是怎么做的呢？她说她做的第一件事是试着找一套能合史蒂夫身的女式西装，然后希望能买到一件一模一样的给那个女人。所以她拿着卷尺去商店寻找夹克
and pants that would fit Steve's measurements. But also she said it had to look masculine enough that it would be plausible that Michael would be confused enough to buy it from a bargain bin. Right. She said that Steve was always so wonderful and generous with his time in the fittings and that oftentimes he would learn about a plot point for a future episode from her. And this was one of those times. She said he walked into a fitting and she was like, so today I'm going to need you to try on all of these women's suits. And Steve was like, for why? And she was like, well, let me tell you, there's going to be an episode next week where this happens because, you know, they would give the crew these scripts
和裤子，要符合史蒂夫的尺寸。但她还说，它必须看起来足够男性化，这样迈克尔才会糊涂到从打折堆里买下它，这在情理之中。她说史蒂夫在试穿时总是那么棒，对时间非常慷慨，而且往往是从她那里了解未来剧集的某个情节。这就是其中一次。她说他走进试衣间，她说，所以今天我需要你试穿所有这些女装西装。史蒂夫说，为什么？她说，好吧，让我告诉你，下周会有一集发生这种情况，因为，你知道，他们会把剧本给剧组
a couple of weeks in advance so they could prepare. But the actors, we would only get them what five days before we started shooting. Sometimes the day of Jenna, sometimes we would get them like an hour before the lunch table read. It depended on what kind of turnaround and how long the script was taking. And I learned about storylines many times in wardrobe. I totally relate to that. I remember learning about Dwight and Angela's wedding because I was going to need to be fitted for a wedding dress. Yeah. Jenna, do you realize that this is the first time we meet Hunter? Yes. Played by Nicholas DeGosto. And Michael's like, you didn't tell me you hired James Vanderbeek. Well, you know, Angela, this guy has a very
提前几周准备，这样他们就能做好准备。但演员们，我们通常在开拍前五天左右才能拿到剧本。有时甚至是开拍当天，有时候甚至是在午餐剧本围读前的一个小时。这取决于周转时间和剧本花费的时间。而且我很多时候是在试装时才知道剧情线。我完全能感同身受。我记得我是因为需要去试穿婚纱，才知道德怀特和安吉拉要结婚的。是的。珍娜，你意识到这是我们第一次见到亨特吗？是的。由尼古拉斯·德戈斯托饰演。迈克尔的反应就像是，你没告诉我你雇了詹姆斯·范德比克。好吧，你知道的，安吉拉，这家伙有着非常
extensive resume. I looked him up, but he was in the movie election with Reese Witherspoon and Matthew Broderick. I love that movie. Yes. He has starred in Gotham and Trial and Error. But I was very excited because he is the lead of Final Destination 5. And I'm a huge fan of the Final Destination movies. I've never seen one of them. What? Well, you hadn't seen Speed. Come on. I've seen Speed. I just hadn't seen Speed in a while. Had you seen Point Break? Of course I've seen Point Break. It came out in 1991 when I was a senior in high school. Of course I saw it. Every girl who was 17 years old saw Point Break. Okay. I haven't seen Final Destination. Is it a scary movie? Do they have to get somewhere
丰富的简历。我查过他，他曾出演过瑞茜·威瑟斯彭和马修·布罗德里克主演的电影《选举》。我很喜欢那部电影。是的。他主演过《哥谭》和《审判与错误》。但我非常兴奋，因为他是《死神来了5》的主演。我是《死神来了》系列电影的超级粉丝。我一部都没看过。什么？好吧，你也没看过《生死时速》。拜托。我看过《生死时速》。我只是好久没看了。你看过《惊爆点》吗？我当然看过《惊爆点》。它于1991年上映，那时我正读高三。我当然看过了。每个17岁的女孩都看过《惊爆点》。好吧。我没看过《死神来了》。这是一部恐怖电影吗？他们必须去某个地方
and if they don't get there, they die or something? It's their Final Destination. Here's what happens. Everyone starts the same but different. There's a major catastrophe. For example, in Final Destination 5, they are supposed to take a bus over a bridge. Who's they? Like a group of kids. It's always like a group of teenagers are traveling somewhere by plane or bus or maybe on the highway. And a major accident happens and they're all killed. Asteroid. Something like that? No. It's not science fiction, Angela. Oh, okay. There's no asteroid that falls from the sky. Okay. It's always like a series of little things that lead to a giant calamity. So someone's tire bursts and then the car spins and then that hits
如果他们没去，就会死还是怎么的？那是他们的死神来了。事情是这样的。每个人都以同样的方式开始，但又有所不同。会发生一场重大灾难。例如，在《死神来了5》中，他们本应坐大巴过桥。谁是他们？比如一群小孩。总是有一群青少年坐飞机、坐大巴或者在高速公路上旅行。然后发生了一场重大事故，他们都死了。小行星。类似这样的事情？不。这不是科幻小说，安吉拉。哦，好吧。没有从小行星从天而降。好吧。这总是像一系列小事情导致了一场巨大的灾难。所以有人爆胎了，然后汽车打滑，然后撞到了
a truck and then things fall off the truck and hit another truck and then something slams into something and then the whole bridge ends up collapsing, right? And they're trapped on the bus, hanging from the bridge or something? No, they're dead. They all die. Oh, oh. Then how do you have a movie? Exactly. Every movie opens up with like a giant disaster moment and then it rewinds and you realize that it's a person's premonition of what's about to happen and that person freaks out and says, everybody get off the bus. We're all going to die. We're all going to die. And he convinces everyone to get off the bus and they think he's crazy and they get off the bus and then everything happens as they envisioned it.
一辆卡车，然后卡车上的东西掉下来砸中了另一辆卡车，然后有什么东西猛烈撞击了什么东西，最后整座桥都坍塌了，对吧？然后他们被困在大巴里，悬挂在桥上还是什么的？不，他们死了。他们都死了。哦，哦。那怎么拍成电影？没错。每部电影的开场都是一个巨大的灾难时刻，然后倒带，你意识到这是一个人的预感，预感即将发生什么，然后这个人吓坏了，说，大家都下车。我们都要死了。我们都要死了。他劝说每个人下车，他们觉得他疯了，然后他们下了车，接着一切都如他预料的那样发生了。
But they live because of the person's weird premonition, right? Okay. But here's the problem, Angela. Do they all die anyway? They were meant to die on that bus and they've cheated death and so death is now going to come for them slowly one by one in the order that they would have died in the accident. Okay. Yeah. It's the same plot every time, but they're great. Sounds really stressful. I like movies. I like it. They relax me and I shouldn't say they're relaxing. No, I think they do, Jenna. I think they do because I think I love you, but you will play out the worst case scenario of every situation. Yeah. Yeah. To sort of prepare yourself. Yeah. So I think movies like this are all horrible
但因为那个人的奇怪预感，他们活下来了，对吧？好吧。但问题来了，安吉拉。他们最后还是都死了吗？他们注定要在公路上死去，他们欺骗了死神，所以死神现在要一个接一个地来找他们，按照他们在事故中死去的顺序。好吧。是的。每次的剧情都一样，但它们很棒。听起来压力真的很大。我喜欢电影。我喜欢。它们让我放松，我不该说它们让人放松。不，我认为是的，珍娜。我认为是的，因为我觉得我爱你，但你会把每种情况的最坏情况都演练一遍。是的。是的。为了让自己有所准备。是的。所以我认为像这样的电影都是可怕的
worst case scenarios. Yes. And in your mind, you're like, oh, yeah, I would think about that. I can relate to that. Yes, Angela. Thank you for saying this. I found uncut gems very, I don't want to say soothing, but I just want to say that my brain operates on that level of stress and anxiety all the time. Yes. So when I see it depicted, it's like it cancels it out and I feel like, oh, finally someone's meeting me where I am. Yeah. You feel seen. I think you feel seen. Yeah. So whereas I know like you or Lee watch a movie like that and you're like, I can't handle this. I can't do this, right? Yeah. That's not recreation for me. I don't want to feel like that in my free time. I want to watch Pride and Prejudice.
最坏的情况。是的。在你的脑海里，你会想，哦，是的，我会考虑那个。我能感同身受。是的，安吉拉。谢谢你这么说。我发现《原钻》非常，我不想说具有抚慰作用，但我只想说我的大脑一直都在那种压力和焦虑的水平上运作。是的。所以当我看到它被描绘出来时，就像它被抵消了，我觉得，哦，终于有人在我的立场上理解我了。是的。你觉得自己被看见了。我想你觉得自己被看见了。是的。所以虽然我知道你或李看这样的电影时会觉得，我受不了这个。我做不到，对吧？是的。对我来说这不是消遣。我不想在空闲时间有这种感觉。我想看《傲慢与偏见》。
I want to watch Kiera Knightley say, Mr. Darcy. Mr. Darcy. Yeah. Yeah. Well, anyway, that was a little bit of a tangent, but I just want you to know that's Hunter. So now Roy is coming to collect his final paycheck. You know, Angela must be very excited. She's so thrilled now. Roy and Dwight are in the same room. Oh, anything could happen. Yeah. And there's a moment where Kevin runs out and he goes, Jim, Roy, look out. Like so delayed. It's too late. He's pointing a Twizzler. Is that what it is? It's a Twizzler or a red vine. We had a big, big container of them, remember? In the kitchen. Oh yeah, they were red vines. I remember I got into a big debate on set about the red container. Yes. Because
我想看凯拉·奈特莉说，达西先生。达西先生。是的。是的。好吧，不管怎样，刚才有点跑题了，但我只是想让你知道那是亨特。所以现在罗伊来领他的最后一份薪水了。你知道，安吉拉一定非常兴奋。她现在太激动了。罗伊和德怀特在同一个房间里。哦，任何事情都有可能发生。是的。有个镜头是凯文跑出来喊道，吉姆，罗伊，小心。太迟钝了。已经太晚了。他正指着一根甘草糖。那是那种糖吗？那是甘草糖或红藤果。我们曾经有一个很大很大的容器装着它们，记得吗？在厨房里。哦，对，那是红藤果。我记得我在片场为这个红色容器引发了一场大辩论。是的。因为
I like red vines and then there's the Twizzler camp. And the two don't see eye to eye. You know what? I can enjoy both a Twizzler and a red vine, but if I had to choose, I might go red vine. I'm a red vine. Yeah. Yeah. So there's now sort of this awkward apology moment where Roy apologizes to Jim and Jim's like, yeah, no worries. And then Dwight is ready, you know, in case he's, Roy's going to lunge again, but he's not. He's just embarrassed and he feels bad and he asks Pam if she'll have coffee with him one last time. Yeah. He says he just has a few things he has to get off his chest and she agrees. So then we go to this coffee place. And do you remember this place, Angela? It's a, we see a shot
我喜欢红藤果，然后还有甘草糖阵营。这两派人合不来。你知道吗？我既能享受甘草糖也能享受红藤果，但如果非要选的话，我可能会选红藤果。我是红藤果派的。是的。是的。所以现在有了一个尴尬的道歉时刻，罗伊向吉姆道歉，吉姆说，没事，不用担心。然后德怀特做好了准备，你知道，以防罗伊再次扑上来，但他没有。他只是觉得尴尬，感觉很糟糕，他问帕姆是否愿意跟他喝最后一杯咖啡。是的。他说他有些话必须一吐为快，她同意了。于是我们来到了这家咖啡店。你还记得这个地方吗，安吉拉？这是一个，我们看到了一个镜头
of it and it says the Hungry Fox. It's a real place and it's still there. Yes. And I would go there. They actually, they're, they're sort of one of these places guys where you can get a little bit of everything. It's kind of like a diner and I've had their cheeseburger. It's so good. I used to eat there all the time too because it was very close to our offices and Greg told me that he often in the mornings before he went into work, he would stop there and have breakfast and kind of set his head for the day basically. And so it's kind of cool that we got to shoot at this place that we all really would eat at. Yeah. I, I loved it.
上面写着“饥饿的狐狸”。这是一个真实的地方，而且现在还在。是的。我会去那里。实际上，他们，他们有点像那种你什么都能买到一点的地方。它有点像一家小餐馆，我吃过他们的芝士汉堡。太好吃了。我以前也经常去那里吃，因为它离我们的办公室很近，格雷格告诉我，他经常在早上去上班前顺道去那里吃早餐，基本上以此来调整一天的状态。所以能在一个我们大家真的都会去吃东西的地方拍戏，感觉挺酷的。是的。我，我很喜欢。
It's a little mom and pop place. Well, I have a question for you, Jenna. When I was watching the scene, it occurred to me. I mean, would Pam have wanted the camera crew to come to this? It's such an intimate moment. It's a farewell. And I was so surprised that she would agree to let the camera crew come along. It's interesting that you asked that question because I actually had the same thought. I thought that it was interesting that this was done on camera, but I had another thought which was maybe Pam doesn't want to be alone with Roy. Well, that's true. The camera crew would have been a buffer, especially, you know, we learned
这是一个典型的小夫妻经营的小店。好吧，我有个问题想问你，珍娜。当我看到这个场景时，我突然想到。我是说，帕姆会希望摄制组也跟来吗？这是一个多么亲密的时刻。这是一场告别。我很惊讶她会同意让摄制组一起来。你问这个问题很有意思，因为我其实也有同样的看法。我觉得这件事在镜头前进行很有意思，但我还有另一个想法，那就是也许帕姆不想单独和罗伊在一起。嗯，这倒也是。摄制组可以算是一个缓冲，特别是，你知道的，我们了解到
that Pam had become friends with some of the crew, right? Yeah. Later, we'll find that out. Yeah. So maybe it in some way was this buffer for this moment. And she wasn't sure how that moment was going to play out. Yeah. So it might have made her feel, I don't know, a little better to have them there. Yeah. Okay. I'll buy that. Well, Roy really apologizes to Pam. And she apologizes as well. She says we, you know, we both made bad decisions. But then Roy says, so are you going to date Jim now? And he says it's sort of like, it would be okay with him. Yeah. I don't know if it would be okay if he's just like curious and wanting to know
帕姆和一些剧组人员成为了朋友，对吧？是的。后来，我们会发现这一点。是的。所以也许它在某种程度上成为了这一时刻的缓冲。而且她不确定那一刻会如何发展。是的。所以有他们在身边可能会让她觉得，不知道，好过一点。是的。好吧，我接受这个解释。好吧，罗伊向帕姆真诚地道歉了。她也道歉了。她说我们，你知道的，我们都做了错误的决定。但接着罗伊说，那么你现在要和吉姆约会了吗？他说这话的语气好像，这对他来说是可以接受的。是的。我不知道他是否真的觉得可以接受，还是他只是好奇，想
up front so he knows what he has to hear about, you know, through the grapevine. But Pam says no. And he's like, he has a girlfriend. But Roy is like, I mean, you called off our wedding for the guy and now you're not going to date him. I just don't get you Pam. Well, he calls you a Pami. And you also say, well, there were other reasons too, which I think is Pam just being polite and not, not saying you did this, you didn't do this. She doesn't want to run him, you know, through the ringer and just leaves it at that. But I do think that Roy saying that is planting the seed for what Pam's going to do later.
提前知道，这样他就知道自己会通过小道消息听到什么风声了。但帕姆说不。他说他有女朋友。但罗伊却说，我的意思是，你为了那个家伙取消了我们的婚礼，现在你却不打算跟他约会。我真搞不懂你，帕姆。好吧，他叫你“小帕姆”。你也说过，嗯，还有其他原因，我觉得帕姆只是出于礼貌，没有说“你做了这个，你没做那个”。她不想把他逼到绝境，就此打住了。但我确实觉得罗伊这么说是在为帕姆后来的行动埋下伏笔。
Because it's true. It's true. She did call off her wedding to Roy in part because she had feelings for Jim. If she did not have feelings for Jim, I'm not sure she would have called off the wedding just because they were not a perfect match. I agree. I think her, her feelings for Jim and the way Jim sort of held up a mirror to her life changed her and he is the reason. He's a big, big part of the reason. Yeah. All right. Well, that was, we talked about this with David a little bit. That was a really special scene for me. I love doing that scene with him. I just love doing scenes with David.
因为这是真的。这是真的。她取消与罗伊的婚礼，部分原因确实是因为她对吉姆有感觉。如果她对吉姆没有感觉，我不敢确定她仅仅因为他们俩不是绝配就会取消婚礼。我同意。我认为她对吉姆的感情，以及吉姆照亮她生活的方式改变了她，而他就是原因。他是其中一个非常非常重要的原因。是的。好了。好吧，关于这个，我们之前和大卫聊过一点。对我和说这是一个非常特别的场景。我很喜欢和他一起拍那场戏。我就是喜欢和大卫一起拍戏。
He was a great actor. He's a great acting partner and I was really sad knowing that that was going to be the last scene we would do for a while. I know. You guys had a really special thing and I loved being able to watch that scene. He was kind of the first major regular character who had been with us from the beginning who was leaving the show. Yes. Yes. And that was, we'd been through a lot. You know, he was part of our origin story. He
他是个伟大的演员。他是个极佳的搭档，一想到这将是我们好一段时间里拍的最后一场戏，我真的很伤心。我懂。你们俩之间有一种很特别的默契，我也很喜欢看那场戏。他是陪伴我们从一开始走到现在、离开节目的第一个主要常驻角色。没错。没错。那是，我们经历了很多。你知道，他是我们起源故事的一部分。他
was with us when the show was struggling and then he was with us when we started getting awards and it was really weird to say goodbye. Yeah. Well, lady, we should go back to corporate because we've got some unfinished business there. Michael and Jan are in the throes of negotiation and he says, give me a raise or no more sex. And Toby just starts taking notes and Michael's like, watch your right and down, Pervball. And then I'm telling you, Paul Lieberstein as Toby crushes it in this talking head. It's so good.
在我们节目苦苦挣扎时一直陪着我们，然后在我们开始获奖时也一直陪着我们，所以说再见真的很奇怪。好吧，各位，我们该回到公司总部了，因为我们在那里还有些未了的事。迈克尔和简正在艰难地谈判，他说，给我加薪，否则就别想有性生活。托比开始做记录，迈克尔说，注意你的右手边，老色鬼。我跟你说，保罗·利伯斯坦饰演的托比在这个单人访谈里的表现太绝了。太棒了。
He talks about what a groundbreaking case this is going to be when it inevitably goes to trial. It's so good. Well, Michael cannot help but make this personal. Yes. Well, right out of the gate, he says we're lovers. I mean, right, right away. Finally, Jan says to Michael, listen, I can give you a 12% raise, but you have to ask me for 15%. Okay. So just ask for 15 and we'll settle at 12. He doesn't get it. He doesn't get it. He says, I want a 15% raise. She said, we can offer you 12. And he says,
他谈到当这个案子不可避免地进入审判程序时，将会是一个多么具有开创性的案件。太棒了。好吧，迈克尔总是忍不住把这变成个人恩怨。是的。好吧，一开场，他就说我们是恋人。我是说，立刻，马上。最后，简对迈克尔说，听着，我可以给你加薪12%，但你必须向我要求15%。好吧。所以只要要求15%，我们最后定在12%。他没听懂。他没听懂。他说，我要加薪15%。她说，我们可以提供12%。他说，
you said 15. And she's like, oh, Michael. Yeah. Well, he does end up getting his raise. He does. And so does Darryl. And Michael explains that negotiating is an art form. And ultimately, it's more about salary. It's really about the perks, like having sex with Jan. And I mean, moving forward, if Michael ever has another job, which we know he will, how's he going to negotiate? I don't know. I don't know. I don't think he really learned anything. I don't know. Well, now it's the end of the day. Dunder Mifflin. All is quiet. People are leaving. Did you catch as Phyllis is leaving? She mentions it's very sort of under under dialogue as they're leaving. She says that her and Bob are looking at historical
你说了15%。而她的反应是，哦，迈克尔。是的。好吧，他最终确实得到了加薪。他确实得到了。达里尔也是。迈克尔解释说谈判是一门艺术。归根结底，比起薪水，这更关乎福利，比如和简发生性关系。我是说，展望未来，如果迈克尔再找一份工作，我们知道他会的，他会怎么谈判？我不知道。我不知道。我觉得他根本没学到什么。我不知道。好吧，现在到了一天的尾声。邓德米夫林。一切都很安静。人们都在离开。菲莉丝离开时你注意到了吗？她提到了这一点，声音压得很低，就在他们离开的时候。她说她和鲍勃正在河附近看
homes near the river. I did not catch that. What a great nugget. I'm like, what the heck? I cannot get enough of Bob and Phyllis dance. I know I would have loved to see more of them. Something we haven't talked about exactly are all the ways that Jim keeps trying to pay Dwight back. So like, you know, he tries to give him a display case for his bobble head. And he tries to give him this certificate of bravery from the Scranton Police Department. But it's, you know, something they give to little kids. Well, it has a teddy bear on it. And he just throws it away. And Jim just can't figure out how he can repay Dwight. Well, then he finds a way. Yeah, he does. So yeah, everyone's left. Angela and Dwight
历史建筑。我没注意到。多棒的一个小彩蛋啊。我的反应是，搞什么鬼？我对鲍勃和菲莉丝的互动百看不厌。我知道，我本来很希望能看到他们更多镜头。我们还没怎么讨论过的一点是，吉姆一直在试图报复德怀特。比如，你知道的，他试图给德怀特一个放摇头娃娃的展示柜。他还试图给他颁发一个来自斯克兰顿警察局的勇敢证书。但这只是，你知道的，那种发给小孩子的证书。好吧，上面有一只泰迪熊。而他直接把它扔了。吉姆根本想不出该怎么报复德怀特。不过后来他找到了方法。是的，他找到了。所以，是的，大家都走了。安吉拉和德怀特
think they're alone. Angela tells Dwight she's heard tales of bravery. Yeah. A gallant hero. And maybe they'll have to read the report. Toby's report together later. And Dwight just scoops her up and gives her a big ol' smooch. And who walks out of the bathroom? Jim. He sees it all. And he's like, oh my gosh, his face is so brilliant. Now there are two things that the scene made me think of. So number one, I noticed that when Rain comes over to you, he sits on your desk. Was that intentional so you guys would be kind of the same height to start kissing? Always. Always. And almost every scene Dwight and Angela have together, he is seated. Look it up, guys. I totally noticed it. He is what, six foot three. I
以为周围没人。安吉拉告诉德怀特，她听说了他英勇的事迹。是的。一个勇敢的英雄。也许他们稍后得一起读一下报告。托比的报告。然后德怀特一把抱起她，狠狠地亲了她一口。谁从洗手间走出来了？吉姆。他目睹了这一切，他的表情，哦天哪，他的表情太绝了。这个场景让我联想到了两件事。第一，我注意到当雷恩向你走来时，他坐在了你的办公桌上。这是刻意安排的，这样你们开始接吻时身高就差不多了吗？总是这样。德怀特和安吉拉在一起的几乎每个场景中，他都是坐着的。大家去查查看，伙计们。我完全注意到了。他身高是多少，六英尺三。我
am five one. And here's the other thing that the scene made me think of, which is that Jim has this talking head where he says, I will never say a word and now we're even. So this means that Pam never told Jim what she knows about Dwight and Angela's relationship. That's right. Pam completely kept that a secret. Yeah. Pam, I mean, I will say this. Pam does right by Angela over and over. She does. I was like, I guess I had forgotten that Pam never told Jim. Well, I have a little behind the scenes story about this scene. We did probably like three, three or four takes just to get the timing right of Jim walking out and reacting. In one take, Rain sort of does this huge grand gesture where he shoves everything
身高五英尺一。这是这个场景让我想到的另一件事，那就是吉姆有一个单人访谈，在里面他说，我永远不会说出去，现在我们扯平了。这意味着帕姆从来没有告诉过吉姆她关于德怀特和安吉拉关系的所见所闻。没错。帕姆完全把这个秘密保守住了。是的，帕姆，我的意思是，我要说的是。帕姆对安吉拉真的是仁至义尽。她确实如此。我当时想，我好像都忘了帕姆从来没告诉过吉姆。好吧，关于这个场景，我有一个幕后小故事。我们大概拍了三、四条，才把吉姆走出来并做出反应的时机把握好。在其中一条里，雷恩做了一个非常夸张的动作，他把奥斯卡桌子上的所有东西都
off Oscar's desk, you know, he like takes his hand and sweeps across the desk and everything goes flying. And he, and I'm like, he picks me up and lays me down on the desk. And, and we thought it was hilarious. And Jeff Blitz was like, it's probably too much. But that kind of goes with your whole like grape eating, I know, whole like renaissance passion. I know. Oh, look at my ankle. Oh, yeah. I know. But that cracked me up. But yeah, that is not the take we went with. And then before the show ends, Andy returns guys, he is back from anger management. He's not going to blow his second chance. He walks in the office and immediately gets pepper sprayed by Dwight. Yes. This leads to Toby taking away all of
推到了地上，你知道的，他伸手横扫了整个办公桌，东西飞得到处都是。然后他，我是说，他把我抱起来放在办公桌上。而且，我们觉得太搞笑了。杰夫·布里茨的反应是，这可能有点太过头了。但这挺符合你那种吃葡萄的风格，我知道，那种文艺复兴时期的激情。我知道。哦，看看我的脚踝。哦，是的。我知道，但这把我逗乐了。不过，那不是我们最终选用的版本。然后在剧集结束前，安迪回来了，伙计们，他从愤怒管理班回来了。他不会搞砸他的第二次机会的。他走进办公室，立刻被德怀特喷了辣椒水。是的。这导致托比没收了
Dwight's weapons underneath his desk. He had a little Sharpie star thing. What do they call it? You throw the star or Sharpie star. And he had nunchucks and pepper spray all duct taped under his desk. Yeah. I think maybe Toby's next stop should be Creed's drawer. Because remember when Creed was able to whittle the wooden stake, he opened his drawer and he had like a lot of stuff in there. I feel like there's a world where Creed hits a button and his desk flips up and there's stairs that go below the office into an underground bunker. And he has everything you need for any doomsday scenario. Well, Dwight ends this with a talking head saying he's not a hero, just a defender of the office. A real hero is hero from heroes,
德怀特藏在办公桌底下的所有武器。他有一个马克笔飞镖星似的东西。他们叫它什么来着？你扔那个星或者叫马克笔星。他把双截棍和辣椒水都用强力胶带粘在办公桌下面。是的。我觉得也许托比下一站应该去搜查克里德的抽屉。因为还记得克里德能削出木桩的时候吗，他打开抽屉，里面装了好多东西。我觉得在某个平行世界里，克里德按下一个按钮，他的办公桌就会翻转过来，下面露出通往办公室下方地下掩体的楼梯。而且他拥有任何末日求生场景所需的一切。好吧，德怀特最后做了一个单人访谈，说他不是英雄，只是办公室的守护者。真正的英雄是《英雄》里的英雄，
which was an NBC show on at the time. Huge, huge show. Huge, huge show. Remember, why was their big catchphrase protect the cheerleader? I don't remember. Yeah, that sounds right. Save the cheerleader, Sam says. Save the cheerleader. Turns out cheerleader didn't need saving. She had superpowers. Before we say goodbye to the negotiation, Jenna, there's something really important we missed. We did not talk about. In the negotiation? Yeah. What? We find out Ryan's middle name. Yes. Ryan Bailey Howard. Yeah, we also find out that Kelly wants to name their child Usher Jennifer Hudson Kapoor. Well, that's it for the negotiation, you guys. Thank you so much for sending in your questions and to David
那是当时NBC播出的一部电视剧。超级火爆的剧。超级火爆的剧。记得吗，他们当时的经典口号是什么？拯救啦啦队长？我不记得了。是的，听起来对。《英雄》里说，拯救啦啦队长。结果啦啦队长根本不需要拯救。她有超能力。在我们向谈判说再见之前，珍娜，有一件非常重要的事情我们漏掉了。我们没讨论。关于谈判吗？对。什么？我们知道了瑞恩的中间名。是的。瑞恩·贝利·霍华德。是的，我们还发现凯莉想把他们的孩子命名为厄舍·詹妮弗·哈德森·卡普尔。好吧，关于谈判就到这里了，伙计们。非常感谢你们发来问题，也感谢大卫
Denman. Yes, David. Thank you so much. Guys, we are getting close to wrapping up season three here. We're in the final stretch of episodes and they are all going to get good. Real good. We'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
登曼。是的，大卫。非常感谢你。伙计们，我们快要结束第三季了。我们正处于最后几集的冲刺阶段，而且每一集都会非常精彩。真的非常精彩。我们下期见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由欧文、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克雷格·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的“办公室女士”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。